Eine Sache, die mir bei der Aufnahme
das letzte Mal, oder die letzten Male beim Schneiden,
ich schneide ja sonst hier nicht so viel, aber
was mir da passiert ist,
ist, dass ich hier bei Reaper die
die Playback-Einstellung
auf
1.5 gestellt hatte, zum Durchhören.
Ach, und dann irgendwie
hatte sich das festgefressen und ich hab's
wieder auf 1.0
runtergestellt und dann war's
also im Endeffekt
war hier noch 1.5 eingestellt, das war
aber Normalgeschwindigkeit aus irgendeinem Grund.
Dann habe ich es auf 1,0 runtergestellt.
Was langsamer? Und dann wurde es langsamer.
Dann klang das, als wären wir
so richtig besoffen gewesen. Wie es halt ist,
wenn du den Podcast auf schnell hörst.
Ich verstehe gar nicht.
Genau. Wenn du den Podcast auf schnell hörst
und dann plötzlich alles auf langsam stellst,
dann klingen die Leute, als wären sie besoffen.
Und Wale sprechen.
Wali.
Genau.
Es gibt auch so geile,
YouTube-Videos, wo sie einfach reden von Donald Trump
einfach mal so auf 80% Geschwindigkeit
drin ist, der klingt so besoffen.
Du kannst so, da gibt es auch eine ganze Reihe von YouTube-Videos,
die Musik von Justin Bieber oder anderen
vielleicht etwas beliebteren Künstlern auf
Faktor 0,05 abspielen
und da klingt das halt wie so richtig geiler
Post-Rock. Och cool, das muss ich mir mal
angucken.
Also zumindest, was mir dann passiert ist,
dass ich irgendwie in Reaper dann die
Aufnahmedatei kaputt war.
Irgendwo in den Einstellungen war halt
es von 1.5
auf 1 durch 1.5 gerechnet wurde.
Und dann musste ich die
Dateien exportieren und in ein neues
Projekt neu einfügen. Und dann
hoffen, dass ich halt zu dem Zeitpunkt noch nicht viel geschnitten hatte.
Okay.
Und dann quasi bei Null anfangen. Neues Projekt
komplett von vorne. Richtig scheiße.
Toll, Reaper. Vielen Dank, Reaper.
Vielen Dank, Reaper. Super kraft.
Genau, du hast mir gerade einen Link geschickt.
Ah ja, hier. Jetzt möchte ich mal ausprobieren,
wie ich hier jetzt, kann ich
auch... Audio vom Rechner?
Audio vom Rechner reinpipen.
Aber ich glaube, ich lasse es lieber einfach sein.
Soll ich mir jetzt dieses
Justin Bieber Video angucken?
Hört man das?
Ist nicht so post-rocky, vielleicht bei dem Titel.
Ach so ein bisschen.
Das hat eher sowas von so ambient, oder?
Aber es klingt um ein Vielfaches besser als Original.
Das ist 9 Minuten 50 lang.
Jetzt geh ich ein bisschen rein.
Ich gehe mal ein bisschen vor.
Das könnte Sigur Rost sein.
Das ist super geil.
Okay, ich habe mir Postmark vielleicht ein bisschen was anderes im Kopf.
Aber das ist toll.
Das gefällt mir.
Das könnte man tatsächlich anhören.
Damit könnte man Leute verarschen.
Ich mache das morgen mal im Büro an.
Was ist denn das?
Was ist denn da?
Justin Bieber.
800% langsamer.
Gut, ich höre mal auf, sonst kriegen wir ja noch
Copyright Infringement oder sowas.
Oh nein, von Justin Bieber.
Wenn das Video noch nicht gesperrt ist, dann hat
YouTubes Content-Advisor auch nicht finden können.
Hi, Kian. Hey, Hendrik.
Wie geht's? Gut, gut, wie immer.
Wie immer. Und dir?
Ja, sehr gut. Ich habe jetzt gerade mal eine Woche
entspannten, langweiligen Urlaub gemacht
und einfach so ein bisschen rumgekammelt.
Das muss ja auch mal sein.
Ich hatte ja irgendwie
letztes Mal schon über Svelte geredet.
Da habe ich einfach jetzt mal, ich war an der
Müritz, es gab kein Internet, aber ich
hatte glücklicherweise noch die
Webseite von Bootstrap und die
Webseite von Svelte im Cache.
Das war cool. Ich konnte richtig auf der,
also merkt man ja sonst nicht,
man hat ja selten kein Internet, aber
ich konnte tatsächlich
innerhalb der Bootstrap-Seite rumklicken,
andere Unterseiten aufmachen und mein Browser hat gesagt,
ja, gibt es noch?
Nee, nee, richtig.
die nächste HTML-Seite und so.
Suchen hat nicht funktioniert.
Wäre ich sofort paranoid gewesen, das gleiche irgendwie.
Außer meint den Cache zu lernen, dann geht's nicht mehr.
Ja, das ist halt
erstaunlich viel, was heutzutage im Cache ist.
Ich weiß das letzte Mal, als ich in die Cache-Einstellung von Firefox
reingeschaut habe, das war so Firefox
09.
Da war die Forteinstellung noch
50 Megabyte. Ich will gar nicht wissen, wie es momentan ist.
Wahrscheinlich ein bisschen mehr.
Hoffentlich nicht.
Und ich habe mir endlich mal eine To-Do-App gebaut.
Nice. Und ich hatte irgendwie vor
zwei, drei Folgen, wir haben mal erzählt,
diese ganzen JavaScript
Frontend Frameworks, ich habe ja keine Ahnung
von JavaScript Frontend Frameworks, die
lassen sich so über das Knie brechen
mit, es gibt so einen zentralen Datenstore
und der Rest ist ein Rendering-Code, der
diesen Datenstore irgendwie repräsentiert.
Und ich habe mich neulich hier mit dem Andi getroffen,
der DVB.js
Hauptmaintained.
Mittlerweile Hauptmaintained.
Und er hat gesagt, ja klar, das ist ja bei allen
so, das ist ja auch bei Ember so, das ist ja auch
bei dem so, und dann kommt es eher noch drauf an.
wenn du bei Vue für eine Art von Redux
Wrapper drumherum bauen willst, wenn du eine größere
Container hast, wenn du eine größere Anwendung hast,
dann nimmst du das Observable
oder wenn du ganz viele State Machines bauen
willst, dann nimmst du irgendwie
Redux Saga und ich dann so
Redux macht doch auch
selbst der Redux-Maintainer sagt, nehmt man nicht mehr
Redux oder sowas, vielleicht ein bisschen zu groß
ja, fand ich dann krass
der hatte sich dann noch tiefer eingegraben
als ich, aber dieses ganze Frontend-Six
habe ich halt komplett ausgesprochen, das war das erste Mal
dass ich überhaupt irgendwas mit einer GUI gebaut hätte.
Ich habe die letzten zehn Generationen davon komplett verpasst.
Von Webzeugs?
Fuck is Redux Saga.
Ich habe es nie gehört.
Keine Ahnung.
Und es ist, du beschreibst irgendwie Übergänge zwischen States damit.
Also dein Datendings, dein zentraler Datenstore ist ja der State deiner Applikation.
Aber wenn du jetzt eine Geschichte erzählst durch deine App hindurch,
man loggt sich erst ein, dann kommt man dorthin, dann passiert das.
Wenn ich das mache, dann das.
Wie bildest du das ab?
Und das kannst du tatsächlich mit den Frameworks
noch nicht so gut abbilden.
Da hast du dann irgendwelche Strukturen, wo du sagst,
ich rufe diese Funktion auf, die mein State beeinflusst.
Aber ist das irgendwie gezielt?
Das ist ja keine State Machine quasi,
sondern die schreibt einfach bloß in deinen Datastore rum.
Und das macht dieses Saga.
Aber das ist alles, was ich darüber geweiß habe momentan.
Saga ist quasi ein Play on Worlds an der Stelle.
Weil es ist eine Geschichte.
Ja, quasi.
Aber frag mich jetzt nicht danach.
Ich habe es mir gar nicht wirklich angeguckt.
Es kann auch sein, das ist gar nicht Saga,
sondern sowas ähnliches hieß.
Aber ja.
Dass es nicht alles gibt.
Krass.
Ich bin aber mit Swell immer noch ziemlich happy.
Ich bin einfach total geflasht, dass du das baust.
Es gibt ein VS Code Plugin,
dass er dir an Stellen zeigt, dass du es halt
so nicht kompilieren würdest.
Was du baust, ist im Endeffekt pures HTML
mit ein bisschen JavaScript drin.
Ganz minimale
Template-Syntax, einfach bloß
if und each und sowas.
Und das war's und das kompiliert runter und ist zum Schluss
30k groß oder sowas.
Ich find das geil, dass du mir gezeigt hast, dass das alles in einer
Binary am Ende in deiner Rust-Binary landet
mit dem Server. Ah ja, genau.
Reinkompiliert in die Binary.
Da kann man schöne Sachen machen.
Einfach so ein Frontend für so eine
Kommandozeilen-Anwendung.
Baust mal eben mit Rocket
einen kleinen REST-Service. Stimmt,
das ist cool. Das hatte ich da halt
mitgemacht. Du startest das, ich hab einen kleinen REST-Service
gemacht, der das startet,
der diese Svelte-App aus
surft und dann einfach
mit sie selbst spricht
und das alles innerhalb von einer
Binary ist schon ganz cool.
Das hat schon echt was, das gefällt mir.
Das ist das, wo ich auf Twitter mich gefreut habe,
dass ich es geschafft habe, die Frontend-App
auf 30k runterzukriegen
und das in die Binary beim Bauen
mit so einem bestimmten
Macro-Crate einzubauen
und das habe ich auf Twitter geboastet.
Total schick, die gesamte Frontend-App
in dem Binary von dem Server mit drin.
Schreibt mich der Blitz an.
I'm not impressed.
Lisp was able to do this for 30 years now.
Das ist schlimm, diese alten
Leute. Das ist ja schön, dass
Lisp das kann, aber das weiß
heute keiner mehr. Deswegen
muss das immer mal wieder
hochgekocht werden, dass sowas möglich
ist. Und ich meine, mach das
sowas mal mit einer Frontend-
Anwendung, mit einem anderen
Setup, wo du allein schon 500k
Framework mit runterladen musst.
Das schlimm ist ja meistens auch nicht.
der Bike-Chat geht ja weiter.
Achso, ja, du meinst nicht den Jagd-Geschäft,
du meinst den echten Bike-Chat.
Der Jagd-Schäft, da gibt es immer noch keine Folge von, oder?
Der ist jetzt gerade im Rauskommen.
Also möglicherweise, wenn diese Folge online ist,
gibt es die erste Folge sogar schon.
Sean Griffin hatte zumindest irgendwann mal
auf Twitter gepostet, I just recorded a podcast.
Da haben alle gedacht, oh, das war wahrscheinlich gerade eine Bike-Chat-Folge.
Aber das letzte Mal, als ich ihn darüber habe
schreiben sehen, hat er gerade
nach anderen Hosts gesucht.
Also vor zwei Tagen hat er zumindest ein Skyncher gepostet,
den Feed-Link bei Apple Podcasts
eingetragen hat. Ja, cool. Nice.
Dann können wir uns ja langsam mal raussuchen.
Zumindest, Bike Chat kann man sich trotzdem
weiter anhören, neuer Host, neue Themen.
Das fände ich aber eigentlich ganz interessant,
weil es jetzt auch immer andere Themen abfrühstückt,
die ich... Nicht nur Diesel
und Active Record. Genau.
Nicht, dass ich dem nicht gerne zuhöre,
aber es gibt halt noch andere Themen.
Halt dich für ein Gerücht.
War das... Ach nee, das war
gar nicht im Bike Chat. Das war im
JS Party Podcast.
Interview mit einem der
Maitainer von Ember, wo sie auch erzählt haben,
wir haben diese krasse,
die haben irgendwie eine VM,
die ihre Template-Sprache ausführt
und die haben sie dann in Rust gebaut, um sie
in WebAssembly zu kompilieren,
um dir was auszuliefern, damit die
Templates, die Ember baut, könnt ihr
dann, was ihr da runterlädst, ist
eigentlich Binary und das wird dann bei dir
irgendwie schneller das zu parsen,
als JavaScript auszuführen, was irgendwie
um Dumm, ich könnte es gar nicht wirklich nachvollziehen,
Ich empfehle diese
JS-Party-Folge über
Ember nochmal anzuhören.
Aber na gut. Klingt ja mal sehr
interessant. Hier, ich habe eine coole neue Programmiersprache
entdeckt. Oh!
Keine Folge akronomisierbar ohne neue
Programmiersprache. Ja, die von letzter Woche
auch sehr gefallen. Was waren das nochmal?
Ich komme gar nicht mehr auf den Namen, hört einfach nochmal Folge 23.
Genau. Dieses Mal ist es
Enterprise TM.
Das packe ich mal, das ist, nehme ich das einfach als
mein, wir machen heute mal einfach eine Star-Folge.
Warum nicht?
Das packe ich mal in die Shownotes.
Und zwar Enterprise.
But while
following on the footsteps of
Rockstar, das ist übrigens eine andere Programmiersprache,
die habe ich mir noch gar nicht angeguckt.
Rockstar ist eine Programmiersprache.
Rockstar Programming Language Specification.
Das ist einfach ein Repo, was eine Sprache spezifiziert.
Die ist allerdings nicht implementiert.
Das sind ja die besten Sprachen.
Also die Specs sind
the following
are the specifications of Enterprise TM.
Language.
Warum heißt das eigentlich immer
The Language?
Also ich kann mich...
Habe ich das gerade auf Englisch gesagt?
Warum heißt das eigentlich immer
The Language?
Also ich kann mich an dieses klassische Buch erinnern,
The C Programming Language.
Und da hat es noch Sinn ergeben, weil
die Programmiersprache C
nach der Programmiersprache B und A war.
The Go Programming
Language
folgt ja eigentlich in dem
Footsteps davon.
Einfach garbage collected
das C sein wollen.
Aber das Buch
The Rust Programming Language,
warum heißt es nicht
The Programming Language Rust oder
The Programming Language Enterprise DM?
Das ist sehr viel Deutscher, glaube ich.
Der Ansatz.
Es klingt
eleganter, The Rust Programming Language.
Bei Swift passt es irgendwie wieder nicht.
The Swift Programming Language? Das ist ein Adjektiv.
Das klingt falsch.
Bei Swift passt es irgendwie, ne?
Da klingt es falsch.
Ich kann den Grund nicht sagen.
Das klingt dann einfach nicht so hip,
wie Swift klingen muss.
Zumindest, wir schweifen ab.
The Enterprise TM Language.
Was macht das aus? Ich sehe Kommentare.
Also Chapter 1 ist nur über Kommentare.
Es gibt irgendwie diverse Formen von Kommentaren.
Es gibt Line Comments.
This is a boring line comment.
The line comment is useful when you want to restate
what the next line does. Here is an idiomatic
example. Comment
adds one to a counter. Und darunter steht
counter plus plus.
Da stehen drei Semikolone.
Block comment. This is a block comment.
Das ist einfach hier
slash Sternchen, Sternchen, slash.
The block comment is useful when a comment is long,
like explaining some implementation.
Okay.
Gut. Hier geht es noch darum,
dass so ein block comment mindestens drei Zellen lang
sein muss, sonst ist es nicht valide.
Copyright comment.
slash copyright logo
copyright logo slash
Every Enterprise program must begin with a copyright
notice, else it will not compile and fail
with an unexpected, non-disruptive, open-source
exception.
It's customary to
cover non-trivial implementations of
Enterprise-CM with a copyright and
a comment. On top of that
add an NDA comment
see below, NDA comment
slash NDA, NDA slash
the following code can only be read
If you sign the NDA 375-1,
if you happen to read it by mistake,
send a written letter to our legal department
with two attached copies immediately.
Passive-aggressive comment.
Slash?
The next bit is oh so lovely.
That's the whole thing.
But it's good.
The first thing is,
things like irony may be a problem in communication.
To solve this problem and ensure proper communication,
Enterprise TM, also passive-aggressive
comments, so the reader must assume the opposite.
Das ist schön
Anzeigen von so einer Ironie.
This is some beautiful code.
Wenn man schon nicht das
offizielle Ironiesatzzeichen benutzt, dann
gibt es mir nicht spezifizierte Ironie-Comments
oder passive-aggressive-Comments.
Das Interview-Comment, das kann ich leider nicht aussprechen,
das ist einfach Slash und dann
Shrug-Aski-Art, Shrug-Aski-Art, Slash.
Hex-Aski-Art, wie man immer diese
Hack-Moji nennt.
Der Inhalt von dem Comment ist
This could have been done in
O of 1 complexity if I had the time.
Time to market comment
slash soon
Using a while
here would be more
performant.
Performatic.
Using a while here would be more performant.
Das ist ein besseres Wort.
Deadline-Comment, das ist das gleiche mit...
Wie fucking viele Comments kennen diese Sprache?
Das hört irgendwann auf. Jetzt kommt Classes.
Also Classes müssen
im Hungarian-Case sein und
müssen immer mit einem Enterprise-y
Suffix aufhören. Also sowas wie...
Enterprise-y. Ich kann dir mal ein Beispiel
aus unserer Codebase vorlesen.
Schreibt die Enterprise-Code?
Nur wenn man nicht aufpasst.
Aber ich habe Manager,
Collector, irgendwas, was mit
E-H aufhört. Abstractor.
Du kannst immer diesen herrlichen
von wegen, dass Managerklassen
absolut zu Recht Managerklassen
heißen, weil sie genau das sind, was draufsteht.
Also sie sind viel zu groß und niemand hat eine Ahnung,
was sie tun.
Viel zu viele Aufgaben.
Ich habe auch manchmal,
wenn ich so internen Code, interne Funktionen
lese, da steht dann
Manage Things, irgendwas drin.
Dann lese ich mich durch, was Manage macht.
Und dann sehe ich,
das geht drüber und schmeißt irgendwelche raus,
die nicht mehr da sind
oder die nicht mehr an sind.
Das sounds about right.
Ja, da kann man noch dran schreiben
remove die und jene.
Das kann auch in dem Titel besser drinstehen.
Descriptive Code ist echt
eine schöne Virtue.
Ja, also lest euch das mal weiter durch.
Ich will es gar nicht weiter spoilern.
Das war jetzt mindestens 30% von...
Oh Gott, wie lange ist dieses Dokument noch?
Extensions and File Structure wird geil.
Deine Datei
liegt dann zum Beispiel in dem Ordner
comp slash enterprise slash disruptive
slash deep slash learning slash data
slash science slash holistic
slash fiss slash bus slash
Synergic
Synergy
slash framework slash manager
fdc deep learning
data science holistic fiss bus
synergic framework manager
punkt etm. Ach, die Dateiänderung
ist übrigens großes etm.
Mit einem
ASCII-etm.
The folder structure depends on
the
name of your disruptive
Class. Let's say the disruptive class is called,
das was du gerade gesagt hast, each word represents
a nested folder you have to create in addition
to the standard com enterprise disruptive.
So you're froh, holy
fucking what?
Wenn die Datei so heißt, dann musst du
das überall, wo ein Großbestabe ist,
aufspalten. Finde ich absolut sinnvoll.
Und einen Unterordner draus machen. Absolut richtig.
Gibt's denn noch, ne? Ja.
So macht man das hoffentlich eh schon.
Nachher findest du deine Datei nicht wieder. Ja eben.
Du kannst es sicherstellen, dass alles
X-Over-Gamespace ist.
complicated types
only make software complicated
so EnterpriseDM has a minimal
list of types, money, string
bool, list
o1type, xml und null
money
here's how you declare
a variable, var type name equals
value, semicolon, semicolon
type is one of the types above
name is any char sequence
you want
as long as it doesn't exceed 8 Characters.
Okay.
Das Geilste finde ich ja da unten eher.
The instructions must be ended with 3 semicolons.
This adds clarity to where it ends,
beats OCaml by one,
and makes your
semicolon key weathered over time,
so it will look like you work a lot.
Ich finde das Beste,
beats OCaml by one,
als Grund.
Oh man.
Oh geil.
Das war eine herrliche Sprache.
Ich habe mir eigentlich OCaml in Form von
Reason reingezogen,
aber da war halt das Erste, was die mit OCaml
gemacht haben, ist, dass sie gesagt haben, wir nehmen OCaml,
aber ändern die Syntax.
Was etwas Menschenlesbares.
Konventionelleres, ja.
Ist ja nicht so, dass die
C-Syntax-Konvention irgendwie
Menschenlesbar ist, aber
zumindest hat man sich irgendwie dran gewöhnt.
Ich habe echt Probleme mit Go zu lesen.
Wenn ich mir das angucke,
und davon abgesehen, dass du immer dein Syntax-Hilibrating ausmachen musst,
damit du eine True Experience hast.
Das gehört dazu. Das sollte Go-Format
eigentlich irgendwie enforcen.
Aber irgendwie ist die Syntax von
Strukturen in Go einfach nicht klar. Du hast irgendwie
jetzt ein bisschen was zu
Go2, dem Draft, hier angelesen?
Genau, ich habe bloß den mal mit hier reingeschmissen in die Shownotes,
weil Go ja jetzt,
also die planen Go2 aktuell
für das Go2 Draft.
Dadurch, dass die jetzt ja langsam
Dependency Management hinbekommen mit diesen Go-Modules,
über die wir ja auch schon gesprochen hatten,
finde ich es eigentlich ganz cool, was sie hier reingeschrieben haben.
Eigentlich gibt es prinzipiell
zwei Features.
Also es gibt drei Features, aber was Error Values
sind, interessiert mich gar nicht. Es gibt prinzipiell
zwei große Features für Go2.
Zum einen Error Handling.
Anscheinend geht es vielen Go-Entwicklern
auf den Sack zurecht, dass du quasi
in jeder zweiten Zeile ein
Error Handling machen musst.
Überall, so wirklich jede zweite
Zeile ist Error Handling.
Und deswegen haben sie sich gedacht,
andere coole Sprachen, wie Rust,
haben da ja sowas, zum Beispiel diesen Fragezeichen-Operator,
dass du, wenn du in einer Funktion bist,
die ein Return-Type hat, der
mit dem Error weiter hochpappeln kann,
dann kannst du in Raster dieses Fragezeichen hinten dran
hängen und dann wird einfach, falls dein Error
rausfliegt, dir einfach hochgeschoben und falls
kein Error rausfliegt, wird der Wert direkt
aus dem Result raus und du kannst
ihn weiter bearbeiten. Das finde ich super schick
und die Go-Leute
haben sich gedacht, das ist cool, das machen wir leicht
kaputt und dann bauen wir es ein.
Ich habe glaube ich
irgendwann vor einiger Zeit mal ein
Video von einem, der
Go-Leute gesehen, wo er erklärt hat,
warum sie das und das so und so machen,
dass sie irgendwie überlegen, wie sie es machen.
Warum scheinen sie sich immer für komische Sachen zu entscheiden?
Das ist schlimmer als bei C++ quasi.
Die alte Aussage,
ich meine, es war von Rob Pike
oder dem anderen Typen, aber ich glaube Rob Pike,
also einer der Go-Maintainer,
der gemeint hat, dass Go mit Absicht
eine schreckliche Sprache ist, weil die ja von
Studenten
beschrieben wird, hauptsächlich, die sie gerade
aus der Uni raushieren und sie bei Google
anfangen und die Leute haben einfach keine Ahnung, wie man
guten Code schreibt und deswegen haben sie Go so geschrieben, wie es ist.
Das hat der mal offen so
rausgehauen.
Damit hat er aber, glaube ich, argumentiert, warum
Go eine einfache Sprache sein sollte.
Ja, aber warum explizit so?
Wir wollen nichts mit abgefahrenem Typsystem, weil die Leute
sind ja alles keine Doktoren,
sondern das sind Studenten, die würden sowas nicht verstehen,
deswegen haben wir es möglichst einfach.
Was eine beschissene Aussage.
Aber was ich mir an diesem,
wir returnen zwei Sachen,
den Wert und den Error
und dann kann man das irgendwie so
pseudo-destructurieren.
Was mir daran immer auffällt, ist, dass es irgendwie absolut nicht zu Ende
gedacht ist. Also zum einen ist es
unterabstrahiert auf eine Art und Weise.
Bei einer Sprache, wo man sich denkt, das wäre eigentlich praktisch, wenn man
zwei Sachen zurückgeben könnte. Da ist halt so die erste
Reaktion, da gibt es irgendwie definiert
einen Wert und einen Fehler, weil
man könnte ja einen Fehler zurückgeben. Aber es ist halt
nicht abstrahiert genug. Du könntest jetzt sagen, ich habe eine Sprache,
da habe ich Tupel und die Structuring, da kann ich
zurückgeben, welchen Tupel von irgendwas, was ich will
und dann sage ich auf der linken Seite beim Binding,
schreibe ich eine ähnliche Struktur rein
und dann habe ich das. Python hat das,
Swift hat das,
C++ kriegt das jetzt, ja.
Und bei Go haben sie sich gedacht, nee, Tupel, das machen wir
da nicht. Unser Error-Komma ist was
Besonderes. Eben, das ist was Besonderes. Das ist ein
Sprach-Weature. Das ist nicht irgendwie was,
was so gebaut ist, dass man es nutzen kann.
Wenn mich nicht alles täuscht, kannst du sowas auch nicht selber machen.
Ähnlich in Go. Du musst dich an
diesen Schrott halten. Du kannst auch nicht sagen, ich mache
jetzt mal was, was zwei andere Sachen zurückgibt.
As far as I know, nein.
Ich hoffe, ich habe ja keinen Scheid, aber soweit ich weiß, geht das
nicht. Du kannst nur diesen blöden Error-Pointer
als Zweiterrückerwert haben. Aber was sie
halt jetzt gemacht haben, ist, sie haben halt ein Check-Keyword
ins Leben gerufen und dieses Check-Keyword ist
prinzipiell, das wir vorher gesagt haben.
Du sagst Check und dann
ein Funktionsaufruf. Falls dein Error rauskommt,
musst du innerhalb von einem Scope sein, der auch ein Error
returnen kann. Dann wird der Error return und falls
kein Error rausfällt, dann machst du mit deinem Wert weiter,
den du da drin hast.
Auf den ersten Blick, ja, ist dieselbe
Idee, bloß haben sie total verpeilt, was
einer der vielen tollen Werte von dem Fragezeichen-Operator
ist, dass man es halt chainen kann.
und das kannst du nicht mit einem fucking Keyword.
Musst du jetzt in Klammern
zehn Aufrufe rappen und dann wieder diese blöde
Falschrumme-Lesweise von wegen, du musst
ganz innen der Klammer aus anfangen und
schrittweise sich nach außen arbeiten.
Aber sowas macht man ja in Go eh nicht, habe ich mir
sagen, das ist auf ECA News, weil Method Chaining
das sieht man einfach nicht, weil das ist ja nicht
idiomatic.
Als ich im Urlaub war, habe ich
Clean Code gelesen.
Da waren ein paar Sachen dabei, die
haben wir aufgeschrieben, das ist gar nicht ganz sinnvoll,
aber sowas wie Method Chaining wurde da auch als Anti-Pattern beschrieben,
weil du ja quasi, du hast was in der Hand,
beziehungsweise du hast Objekt A und rufst Methode drauf auf,
die dir Objekt B gibt, auf dem du sofort eine Methode aufrufst.
Dann musst du ja wissen, was es dir für einen Typen zurückgibt
und dann musst du so weiter und so fort.
Das ist absolut richtig, ja.
Aber an Stellen, wo du weißt, dass du eine Monade zurückbekommst
oder was Iterierbares, was ein bestimmtes Interface wiedererfüllt ist,
das ist natürlich absolut sinnvoll.
Man darf es natürlich generell nicht übertreiben, das ist bei jedem Feature so.
Die hatten hingeschrieben, die hatten auch was, wo sie drei Methoden hintereinander gechained haben
und haben dann
gesagt, das ist eigentlich nicht schön, das lässt
irgendwie auf sloppy Codes
da hinweisen. Wir möchten bitte schreiben,
Variable A ist gleich
das und dann
Variable B
ist gleich Variable A.
Und dann Variable C ist Variable B.
Wow, da hat man ja viel mehr
Transparency. Die Typen kann ich da auch nicht
lesen, wenn die infariert werden.
Ich habe irgendwie festgestellt, weil ich mich auf Arbeit ständig
mit meinem Kollegen streitet,
der
JavaScript-Purist ist und irgendwie
Typen in TypeScript für Toten Code hält.
Das ist allerdings auch
klar. Ja, es ist aber eine spaßige Art und Weise.
Da habe ich auch irgendwann
angefangen zu argumentieren
beziehungsweise festgestellt, dass es eine gute
Argumentation ist. Typen sind
dann was Schönes, wenn du sie nicht sehen musst.
Was die Leute an
getypten Sprachen der alten Schule
scheiße finden, wie zum Beispiel Java
und C++ vor Auto, ist
Du musst überall vorne hinschreiben,
Typ, Name
ist gleich irgendwas.
Erstens flackert das,
weil jedes
Variable Binding
mit einem anderen Keyword anfängt, nämlich mit dem
variablen Typen, das ist irgendwie mit dieser
Präfix-Syntax
anstatt let-kunst-var
irgendwie. Und zum anderen,
gerade bei Java ist ja das
klassische Beispiel, dass du vorne den Typen hinschreibst
und hinten den Typen reinschreibst und du fragst dann
Array of Int
List ist gleich
New Array of Int.
So heißt kein Typ in Java. Also braucht mindestens so 3-4 Wörter,
damit das dann ergibt.
Idiomatisches Java ist.
Factory Bean Generator.
Jetzt bist du also realistisch.
Ja, ja, ja.
Nee.
Aber ja, ich stimme dir absolut zu.
Das ist unheimlich verbos, wenn man das so machen muss.
Und einfach unschön zu lesen.
Und dann merkt man, hat diese Noise da mit drin
und die macht das alles kaputt.
Und ich habe es auch, als Swift rauskam,
ich habe mit Swift direkt am Tag 1 angefangen,
habe mich direkt zu Hause gefühlt.
Aber wenn man das halt,
ich bin damit mit in die iOS-Szene eingestiegen
und habe halt viel Kontakt über Leuten gehabt,
die schon seit Jahren Objective-C geschrieben haben.
Und viele haben sich halt auch hingesetzt und gesagt,
also gerade bei den Coco-Heads-Meetups auch,
Coco-Heads-Meetups,
dass das ja kacke ist,
weil man sieht gar nicht, was die Typen sind.
Das ist halt, ja, Type-Inference.
Man gewöhnt sich dran
und man hat halt alles idiomatische Sachen.
Und man weiß doch, was... Also klar, wenn man
neuen Code vor sich hat, manchmal muss man halt in der
IDE draufklicken und schauen, was ist das?
Und manchmal will man es auch verifizieren. Aber
das...
Für mich ist das kein Stock in meinen Speichen.
Ich kenne auch so einen Kommentar von so einem C++-Entwickler,
der sagt, ja, Auto ist schön und gut, aber
ab und zu möchte man mal wissen, was das ist. Und dann schreibt man es halt hin.
Man kann es ja auch wünschen, ja.
Ich schreibe jetzt mittlerweile in Code-Reviews bei TypeScript-Leuten
ran,
das ist Overtyping. Wenn sie zum Beispiel irgendwo
ein Lambda reingeben oder ein Callback reingeben,
kannst du ja eine Signatur von dem
Callback reinschreiben, was es für Parametertypen
angibt. Das
ist allerdings absolut unnotwendig,
weil die Signatur von der Funktion, wo du
das Callback reingibst, schreib dir vor, was
das für eine Signatur sein muss. Und damit
shadowst du vielleicht irgendwie eine Abstraktion.
Wenn du zum Beispiel, du kannst ja dummerweise Typen haben,
die miteinander kompatibel
sind, weil sie strukturell ähnlich
sind oder strukturell gleich sind.
Deswegen, Typen reinschreiben
ist schon fast
ein Antipadal.
Das ist auch super sinnvoll. Also ich finde es auch sehr schön,
wenn man in Zwift an wie vielen Stellen einfach mal
wirklich nicht nur dem Compiler
unter die Arme greift. Manchmal ist das leider notwendig,
dass der allein nicht versteht, was da
alles zu ambiguous ist und man muss dann
typen.
Bei TypeScript mache ich es teilweise so, wenn mir irgendwas nicht klar ist,
dann schreibe ich bewusst einen falschen Typen rein
und dann sage ich
const foo.void
ist gleich irgendwas, damit der Fehler mir dann
sagt, so und so ist not assignable
zu Void.
Das geht wunderschön. Also die Type Inference in Typescript
funktioniert groß gezeichnet.
Also zumindest in der Richtung ist mir noch nicht viel kaputt gegangen
in Swift, aber manchmal willst du es einfach hinschreiben,
damit es halt lesbarer wird. Und das finde ich auch absolut okay.
Es gibt ja, ich meine, die Syntax gibt es dir ja,
dass du das machen kannst. Bisschen magisch
finde ich es ehrlich gesagt in Rust, wo das ja wirklich
zu so drei Ebenen
höher noch geht, dass du teilweise
so einen Return-Wert in der Funktion und dann
schreibst du noch so einen Punkt into hintendran oder so,
aber nicht der Return-Wert der Funktion,
sondern der Caller der Funktion auf der anderen Seite gibt
irgendwo den Typen damit an. Für Rust ist das
alles klar, aber du schaust so hin,
ich sehe hier nirgendwo den Typen. Der Compiler
sagt, das passt alles, deswegen glaube ich dem
jetzt mal, aber wo zum Teufel steht hier
was? Das ist nirgendwo.
Ich habe mich manchmal erwischt,
in Rust gibt es das Into Trade,
das heißt, du schreibst ja dann hin,
wenn du einfach bloß,
das ist ein Trade, das heißt groß into,
und hat eine Methode, das heißt klein into,
und wenn du das irgendwo in den Lambda
reingibst, kannst du einfach so schreiben,
into, into, und ich habe mich schon erwischt,
dass du irgendwie, und das geht in vielen Stellen,
wenn du irgendwie was,
eine Option von Typ X kriegst,
du musst aber hinten Typ Y raushauen,
dass du einfach
zwischendrin Map into into schreibst.
Was super ist,
weil der Compiler findet
statisch die korrekte Methode, um
X nach Y abzubilden raus und fügt
die an dieser Stelle rein.
Aber es ist halt super witzig, das kann man immer mal so
ausprobieren. Und dann gibt es noch den,
du weißt schon besser als ich,
Operator, nämlich
und und Sternchen
oder Sternchen und und, das
mit Doppel-D-Referenzierung und neue
Referenz erzeugen, wobei
die Typ-Influence auch nochmal ein bisschen schlauer rauskriegt,
was du eigentlich machen wolltest.
Okay, das treibt das jetzt irgendwie so auf die Spitze.
Aber ich habe es schon vorhin gesehen, du schreibst
so ein bisschen Rust-Code, hast so eine Seite Rust vor dir
in einem Editor und es ist halt quasi
alles angestrichen, weil der Compiler meint hier, das ergibt
von vorne bis hinten keinen Sinn. Keiner dieser Typen
ist miteinander kompatibel. Also wenn ich jetzt
hier ein Intuit, oder hier schreibe ich noch
den Typen ran, in dieser einen Stelle plötzlich,
alles passt. The fuck?
Wie ist das denn jetzt aufgegangen?
Ja, das ist, ähm, aber das ist alles,
ist das alles das, was unter hier
Hinlay-Milner-Type-Inference fällt?
Ja, ich habe keine Ahnung.
Also ich meine, wenn das gut funktioniert,
dann ist das klasse.
Wenn du allerdings manchmal den Compiler
hinschreiben musst, damit der es hinkriegt,
damit er nicht abstürzt beim Pompilieren.
Das ist doof, aber Ziel Nummer eins ist natürlich,
dass es für den Menschen davor lesbar ist, immer.
und das heißt natürlich an manchen Stellen
Typen ranschreiben, das heißt an manchen Stellen Typen weglassen,
damit es einfacher vom Kopf her
passbar ist und einfach nur...
An welchen Stellen würdest du dann Typen ranschreiben?
Also ich finde ja diese Konvention von
Rust wirklich sinnvoll, dass du sagst,
bei Funktionssignaturen müssen sie absolut
sein. Ja, da gehören sie hin.
Bei Lambdas müssen sie nicht unbedingt sein.
Da lässt sich sie auch meistens weg, ja,
weil sie an anderen Stellen schon definiert sind, meistens in der Funktion.
Naja, du kannst bei Rust ein Lambda
schreiben und eine Variable
zuweisen und dann erst 50
Zeilen später, wenn du es irgendwo reingehst, wird festgelegt,
was das oben findet. Das finde ich wieder super tricky.
Das ist so typisches Rust-Feature, ja.
Das finde ich ehrlich gesagt tricky. Wenn ich irgendwo
eine Lambda definiere oder eine Closure oder was auch immer,
dann da, wo es halt definiert ist,
da, wo ich den Typen festlege, da würde ich es gerne reinschreiben.
Es sei denn, ich übernehme die halt
irgendwie aus dem Kopf der Deklaration, aber dann ist sie ja dort definiert.
Ja, also ich würde es persönlich nicht mal die Deklaration
schreiben und ansonsten die Type-Inference
arbeiten lassen.
Mir fallen jetzt auch keine konkreten Beispiele ein, muss ich sagen.
Ich habe da jetzt nicht den Style
im Kopf. Ich mache es mehr so,
wie ich es halt sinnvoll finde beim Schreiben.
Also ich finde es schön, dass du halt zum Beispiel, wenn du irgendwo eine Liste
von was zurückgibst, dass du in deiner Funktion ganz
zum Schluss echt nur Collect
sagen musst. Und der weiß von alleine
in Wasser rein collecten soll, anhand
was der Rückgabetyp
der Funktion ist. Das hat schon echt was, das muss ich
auch sagen. Aber ich glaube,
wir brechen gerade alle Podcast-Regeln,
dass man nicht über Code-Beispiele reden soll.
Ich glaube, es ist doch einigermaßen nachvollziehbar.
Wir zeigen uns ja auch gerade keine...
Wir waren ja beim Message-Chaining, aber da haben wir es ja gerade mit dem Collect zum Beispiel.
Du hast so einen Iterator über eine Liste
und machst dann noch fünf Operationen,
einen Map, einen Filter, sonst was, noch zwei Flatmaps.
Keine Ahnung, was du da halt immer machst.
Und das geht halt einfach nicht in Go.
Da habe ich...
Also es geht halbwegs, wenn du es hinschietest,
mit manchen Sachen, aber die machen es halt aktiv kaputt.
Das ist kein idiomatischer Stil.
Und man soll es nicht machen.
Und man würde behaupten, fast Go-Format lässt es gar nicht durch.
Was hast du vorhin erzählt?
Dass Go dir sogar irgendwie vorschreibt,
dass du möglichst kurze Variablen...
Das ist halt idiomatischer Stil,
dass du bestenfalls nur einen Buchstaben nimmst.
Das ist halt so eine dumme Regel.
Gott. Aber jetzt kriegen sie ja
in dem Zweierdraft, beschreiben sie ja, dass
sie irgendwie Generics gibt. Ja, das ist das andere.
Haben sie sich jetzt endlich mal
verstanden, dass Leute das wieder haben wollen?
Was ich tatsächlich witzig dazu habe,
ich habe jetzt keine Kritik explizit hier dran.
Ich finde nur die Syntax
interessant. Also erstmal...
Den Linkspfeil, oder? Den Teil meine ich gar
nicht überhaupt. Ich sehe mal gerade,
dass ich überhaupt keine Ahnung von Go habe. Was macht denn dieser
Links-Pfeil überhaupt? Hier steht
funkmerchchance...
Achso, das ist die
Go-Routine-Channel-Dings-Syntax,
die so mit reinkommt.
Ich habe mich gerade als doch Go
unkenntlich...
Worum es ja eigentlich geht, ist ja, dass du einfach nur
generische Typen verteilst und andere Sachen,
diese generischen Typen implementieren können.
Du kannst die als Substitute
da reinschieben. Und was sie halt noch da drüber
legen, ist, du willst ja manchmal sagen, dass zum Beispiel
hier einen generischen Typen erwartest,
aber ich möchte vorschreiben,
dass dieser Typ mit einem anderen verglichen werden kann,
dass der quasi equatable ist
oder dass der mit einem anderen addiert werden kann
vom selben Typen,
dass der quasi, wie nennen sie es hier, addable ist.
Und das geht in Goals Generics Proposal
über sogenannte Contracts,
wo du, wenn ich das richtig verstehe,
quasi ein Beispiel angibst,
was du damit machen möchtest,
so wie bei diesem Contract Equal hier,
ein Contract Equal mit einem T vom Typ T,
möchtest du, dass T ist gleich T,
T ist gleich T gesagt werden kann.
Und ich vermute einfach mal,
ich habe hier keine Ahnung,
dass der Compiler das da wirklich reinschiebt
und schaut, ob er es machen kann und wenn nicht, dann ist das
halt so. Aber das heißt,
achso, das heißt aber, dass es quasi Ducktyping
ist, oder wie? Von der Idee her,
diese Contracts wirken zumindest arg
danach. Und unten kannst du halt sagen, du möchtest jetzt ein
anderes T haben, was dieses Equal,
diesen Equal Contract erfüllt. Ah ja.
Und dann kannst du das da reinschieben. Also es sieht
halbwegs sinnig aus und das hier ist tatsächlich was,
was Go meiner Meinung nach stark gefehlt hat.
Also an manchen Stellen haben sie zu viele Zeichen,
also Symbole, so
und an manchen haben sie überhaupt keine. Das ist ja echt
set type t equal, da ist einfach
ein Leerzeichen dazwischen. Das kreide ich
dir noch irgendwie an manchen Stellen an, das einfach
zwischen... Also syntaktisch hat Go überhaupt
nichts auf der Reihe. Gar nicht. Allein diese Sachen von
wegen, dass du Arrays
deklarierst mit geschwungene
Ecke, Klammer auf, Ecke zu und dahinter
den Typen. Das haben die ja nur gemacht, haben sie ja gesagt,
weil es einfacher passbar ist.
Von der Syntax her.
Tolles Go. Also entweder du schreibst
die Klammer dahinter oder rundherum, aber das ist ja
echt... Also ich muss sagen,
ich habe Probleme, das hier zu lesen.
Doppelpunkt ist gleich
Keys, dann einmal Klammer auf,
Klammer zu, in String.
Ist das eine Funktion?
Dann nochmal runde Klammern
Map. Das ist jetzt total
Strafe für den Zuhörer, aber
diese Konstruktion,
ich sehe es nicht an, was es ist.
Ich vermute mal, dass hier hinten mit der Map
ein Dictionary anfängt.
Also das ist eine Map von int String?
Ja, der Key kommt in die Klammern rein
und der Witzwelle dahinter.
Es ist einfach eine super hässliche Syntax.
Die machen so viele Verbrechen in dieser Sprache,
die nutzen Tabs.
Oh, gleich tot.
Jetzt haben wir gleich irgendwie zehn Hörer weniger,
die doch Go machen, glaube ich.
Nee, aber ich meine,
ich finde diese Sprache,
persönlich kann der was abgewinnen,
einfach nur, weil sie unglaublich populär ist
und sie hat halt Vorteile im Sinne von,
der Compiler ist super schnell,
ich kann super einfach cross-compile,
es läuft überall.
Das ist beeindruckend, das ist super cool.
Ich fand da eigentlich,
ich dachte immer, boah, Go ist super geil,
das muss ich mal machen, als immer, wenn mir jemand was davon erzählt hat,
habe ich es staunen gekriegt,
ja, ich kompiliere hier mal eben was
und der Compiler spuckt mir auf einmal
Binarys für drei Systeme auf einmal aus,
weil er nichts linken muss, weil sie keine CLIP nehmen,
weil sie alles selber gebaut haben.
Es kompiliert super schnell, man könnte es auch
als Skriptsprache verwenden, indem da einfach den Compiler
und die Exekution von dem Binary
sofort ineinander hängt, so schnell ist der Compiler
und Go-Routines
sind ja auch eine super
Abstraktion gegenüber
Threads. Go-Routines sind auch super schick, ja.
Bis du dann hörst, dass die irgendwie
Scheduling-Probleme machen,
weil du nicht garantieren kannst, dass eine Go-Routine
beim nächsten Mal wieder auf dem gleichen...
Die werden manchmal von Threads zu Threads hin und her.
Ich weiß es nicht. Du kannst bestimmte Betriebssystems
Sachen damit nicht machen, weil du nicht garantieren kannst,
dass die Go-Routine dir nicht
unter dem Arsch wegbewegt wird.
Hat der Florian Giltjahr das letzte Mal erzählt.
Das vorletzte Mal in Folge 22.
Dann denkst du dir,
boah, ja, cool, dann guckst du dir die Sprache an,
findest kein Beispiel mit Syntax-Halliting
und dann ist die Syntax so, dass du dir denkst, oh, was?
Ja, und dann haben sie
eine neue Sprache
und sie haben einfach mal gedacht, ja, Null ist toll,
Null kannst du alles ranklatschen, das Feature übernehmen wir.
Das ist eine Sprache,
wahrscheinlich die von Leuten
erfunden wurde, die ganz viel
so Survivor-Bias haben.
So, ich
mache schon seit 40 Jahren
C. Daunlich plausibel.
Die sagen, das ist alles nicht so schlimm.
Das haben wir schon immer so gemacht.
Das machen wir jetzt einfach.
Error-Handling, viel mehr als
hier ein Error-Typ.
Kriegst du einen Error-Pointer, kannst du schauen, ob das drin ist oder nicht.
Genau. Reicht. Passt.
Ein anderes Bullshit-Feature,
das ich immer noch highlighten möchte, ist, dass
die Default-Werte für alles haben.
Dass jeder Typ einen Default-Wert hat.
Also, es gibt keine uninitialisierten
Variablen oder sowas.
Und Default-Wert für ein Integer ist halt null, glaube ich.
Und das ist halt eine Quelle
für so viele Bugs, wenn da einfach schon irgendein
Wert drinsteckt. Das heißt, warte mal,
wenn ich jetzt ein Binding mache, wie mache ich das?
Das ist jetzt var
x int, dann ist das sofort null.
Oder was?
Ich glaube schon.
Ich mache aber auch schon zu lange kein Go mehr.
Aber du hast auf jeden Fall das Problem, dass
Booleans gibt es nur zwei Werte und jeder
Booleans hat bei Default False.
Ist das
doch nicht sinnvoll?
Du möchtest eigentlich unterscheiden können
zwischen, ich habe es mal
Ich habe es nicht zugeordnet. In JavaScript
ist ja tatsächlich eine von unseren Interviewfragen.
Was ist der Unterschied zwischen
undefined und uninitialisiert?
Es gibt in...
JavaScript hat eher das Problem, dass es zu viele
Negativzustände hat.
Eine Variable kann
undefined sein, sie kann null sein.
Sie kann irgendwas sein, was falsi ist.
Also ein leerer String oder null.
Und sie kann
undeklariert sein, was es ja auch nochmal gibt.
Das heißt, wenn ich auf ein Objekt
Punkt XYZ zugreife,
was ich nie irgendwo deklariert habe,
dann ist das undefined.
Aber wenn ich auf die Variable XYZ
zugreife, dann ist die
undeklariert, das ist eine andere Art
von Fehler und ich könnte dir aber einmal sagen
war XYZ und dann ist die aber
per default undefined.
Was ich nicht zu streng vergleichen darf
mit irgendwas, es gibt doch Leute, die
alles erstmal mit 0 initialisieren,
dann darfst du nicht testen, ob das undefined
ist, weil undefined und 0 ist nicht genau das gleiche.
Yay, aber es stimmt.
Auch eine tolle, tolle Sprache.
Also, wenn die anderen
Podcasts die Regel haben,
dass man nicht über Code reden darf, dann muss es auch
einen Podcast geben, wo wir extra viel
über Code reden.
Genau. Was haben wir noch in unseren Show Notes da drin?
Flatpack 1 ist rausgekommen.
Was ist Flatpack nochmal?
Flatpack, ich habe
extra in diese Show Notes reingeschrieben, weil ich gehofft habe,
ich schoss mir dann extra für die Sendung nochmal an, aber ich bin
leider nicht dazu gekommen. Klassiker, ne?
es gibt Flatpak und die Alternative
dazu ist Snap.
Und das ist quasi ein Packaging-Format
für Linux-Distros,
für Anwendung
out of the box.
Ergo, wenn ich was baue
und ich möchte es auf
Arch oder auf
Debian installieren können, dann kann ich es ja,
muss ich ja bislang eigentlich für diesen
Package Manager dort was bauen, weil es ja
richtig ins System rein installiert wird mit
ich lege die
Libraries an der richtigen Stelle an, ich schaue, dass die
Dependencies in den Versionen vorliegen, dass ich sie
immer ein paar Mal haben muss. Mein System
installiert diese Anwendung.
Ist allerdings, wenn ich hier wirklich mit Apps um mich schmeißen möchte,
irgendwann skaliert das nicht mehr wirklich und du hast
halt Leute, die ihr Leben damit verbringen,
Anwendungen für bestimmte
Distros zu packagen.
Wenn du jetzt was bauen möchtest, wie
zum Beispiel bei VS Code und bei Slack gibt es das.
Ich möchte einfach, dass das jede Linux-Distribution
installieren kann. Dann packe ich das
in so ein Flatpack oder ein Snap.
Das ist leider so, dass da
Ubuntu mal wieder gesagt hat, oh ja, da gibt es so eine Bewegung,
im Open Source. Wir machen unser eigenes und schauen,
ob wir damit gegen Ansagen. Genau,
Flatpak ist irgendwie aus der Gnom-Gegend und
Snap kommt aus der Ubuntu-Ecke.
im Endeffekt ist es glaube ich
sogar so ein bisschen wie bei Docker, dass es
C-Groups verwendet, um die Anwendung
voneinander besser
zu isolieren. Aber genauer eingestiegen
bin ich nicht. Im Endeffekt für den Benutzer ist es auch egal.
Du hast auf jeden Fall
für alle Betriebssysteme gleich
installierbare Pakete. Was du halt machen musst, ist, dass
du für deine Distro
SnapD oder das
Äquivalent von Flatpak installiert hast
und dann hast du ein standardisiertes
Paketformat und das
sorgt dafür, dass es bei dir das ausführbar macht.
Das hat natürlich dann wieder die gleichen Nachteile, wie du bei
Windows und bei macOS hast. Bei macOS hast du ja
diesen Applications-Root-Ordner,
wo alles drinsteht,
in diesen App-Unterordnern.
Da ist quasi jede Dependency
nochmal untereinander
dupliziert drin. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie das
bei Mac funktioniert, wenn sich Sachen
Frameworks teilen, die werden dann wahrscheinlich woanders
installiert, wenn es geht, aber die meisten
sollen wahrscheinlich die Frameworks von
macOS aus dem System selber verwenden.
Aber wenn du zum Beispiel eine große Qt-Anwendung hast
und du hast davon, du hast mehrere
große Qt-Anwendungen auf Mac rumliegen,
dann hast du wahrscheinlich die Qt-Library,
die dann jeder in ihrer eigenen Version mitbringt,
fünfmal auf deinem System.
Und bei Snap oder bei Flatpak hast du das dann auch.
Wahrscheinlich.
Es gibt hier noch Mechanismen, es kann sein, dass ich dir gerade
absolut Stütze zähle, dass die sich wahrscheinlich
darüber Gedanken gemacht haben, wie sie doch untereinander
bestimmte Dependencies teilen.
Aber ja, es
gibt halt länger diesen Ansatz,
wir möchten Pakete installierbar
machen auf unterschiedlichen Distros
und ein einheitliches Format anbieten.
Flatpak 1 ist jetzt raus.
Es ist ja meistens so, dass die Leute
von Ubuntu zwar irgendwie eine Alternative
anbieten, aber das von Gnome sich dann im Endeffekt
durchsitzt. Flatpak ist das von Gnome.
Und Flatpak hat auch diese
total schicke, habe ich das verlinkt,
Flatpak ohne
C.
Ohne C.
Flatpak.org, genau, die haben diese
wunderschöne, flache Seite.
Puh, die ist echt sexy, schick.
Sexy, ne?
Genau.
Ich hab echt noch nichts gehört von Flatpak bisher.
Also Snap hab ich schon mal benutzt auf Ubuntu-System,
aber Flatpak kannte ich nicht.
Ja, mit Flatpak kannst du auch
Slack installieren.
Ich hab jetzt auf meinem Dienst
Ubuntu hab ich's mit Snap gemacht,
Ich habe natürlich eine total andere
schöne Webseite gefunden.
Sentry.
Sentry.io. Das ist jetzt bloß, weil wir jetzt gerade
das ist wieder sehr hörerunfreundlich. Schaut euch mal die Webseite
von Docker an. Da siehst du so
kleine Cartoon-Männchen an Fließbändern
stehen, wo so
bunte Kisten oder
Pyramiden oder Bälle
vorbeifahren. Und das ist so ein bisschen animierte
Grafik, die von Flatpak witzigerweise,
wenn du mal guckst, Flatpak und Docker
die beiden Seiten vergleichst, so gewisse
Designgrundlagen teilen die sich ja wirklich.
Und ich habe jetzt,
die Webseite von Sentry ist witzig.
Die erzählt auch so ein bisschen so eine Geschichte.
Da geht es nämlich um ein System, was dir
notifiziert wird, wenn irgendwelche Fehler in der
Produktion passiert. Da siehst du einen Typen
an seinem Computer sitzen. Das ist so
hell-dunkel. Und da geht mal kurz
dein Telefon an, am Hintergrund siehst du die Stadt und da gehen
einfach alle Lichter aus in der Stadt.
Und das ist die Webseite von diesem Ding.
Okay, Sentry ist doch so ein Error-Reporting-Dings, oder?
Genau.
Ich habe der Armin Ronacher,
Der Typ, der auch Flask geschrieben hat, der arbeitet, glaube ich, bei denen.
Ach ja.
Building Staff at Sentry, der hat letztens einen geilen Tweet rausgehauen.
Der hat Flask gebaut.
A customer's debug symbol fails to be processed by Sentry.
It ran to the 65.000 character limit for a function name.
He has a 140.000 character function name.
Yay, C++.
140.000 Zeichen.
Das ist irgendwie obvyskated, oder?
Es ist 100 pro obvyskated oder generiert.
Das ist ein Compiler-Bug, oder?
Aber what the actual
fuck?
Ich habe das bloß mitbekommen, dass es das gibt,
weil ein Kollege von mir irgendwie einen Pull-Request
da reingemacht hat, es gibt irgendwie für einen Browser
jetzt experimentell eine
Beacon-API.
Das ist wieder so ein...
Meinen die da mit
AI-Beacons?
Nee, ein Beacon ist
und ich verlinke mal
die MDN-Seite
zur Beacon-API, die ist noch experimentell,
Aber im Endeffekt machst du damit
nicht asynchrone, sondern
Fire and Forget HTTP
Requests, um
möglichst sparsam irgendwelche
Telemetry-Daten wegzuschicken aus dem Client.
Und
ja, das ist eigentlich auch
alles. Ich mache einen HTTP-Request
aus dem Browser raus, wo ich definitiv
weiß, dass ich keine Antwort kriege.
Und das macht es ein bisschen leichtgewichtiger.
Das ist eine API, die
in den Browsern teilweise schon
benutzbar ist. Ich meine, das Schöne, wenn es
der Browser-API ist und das alle nutzen, dann kann ich sehr einfach
Telemetry deaktivieren und auch gleichzeitig.
Achso. Naja, im Endeffekt
ist es bloß ein anderes
Interface
zu einem
AJAX-Request. Das ist ja hier XML-HTTP-Request.
Oder nee, ist es nicht.
Aber es ist einfach bloß eine andere API zu einem
HTTP-Request zu einem Post.
Idee klingt ja nicht falsch.
Wenn es Dinge sparsamer macht und
ich nicht auf die Antwort warten muss, dann ist ja
ist ja sinnvoll, das zu nutzen. Warum nicht?
Wenn du eine kommerzielle Anwendung
vertreibst, dann hast du ja am Anfang
irgendwie diesen Haken gesetzt, anonyme
Nutzerdaten. Erstmal, wenn ich irgendwie als
Benutzer eine Anwendung
sehe, wo drinsteht, dürfen wir anonyme Nutzerdaten
wegschicken, dann denke ich mir natürlich,
ja, mittlerweile
denke ich mehr und mehr drüber nach, ja, eigentlich,
ja, los, mach. Wenn es jetzt
nichts ist, was direkt auf meinem System läuft
oder sowas, aber irgendwie
so eine Web-Anwendung ist schon durchaus
sinnvoll. Viele mussten es auch machen.
Ich habe in letzter Zeit mir zum Ziel gesetzt,
solchen Anwendungen, wenn ich irgendwelche Schrottfehler entdecke,
denen auch Bescheid zu geben.
Wie letztens erst bei einer Plattform angemeldet.
Ich konnte mir halt kein Account machen.
Das Register-Formular hat mich halt immer wieder
zurück zu sich selber redirectet.
Ohne Hinweis, keine Fehler in der Konsole, nichts.
Cool.
Support angeschrieben.
Da haben die auch eine App gehabt.
Vielleicht kann ich mich da registrieren.
Oh, ich kann mich nicht registrieren, weil mein Passwort zu lang ist.
Gut, danke.
Den Hinweis hätten sie aber auf der Webseite geben können.
Jetzt habe ich den Support mal geschrieben.
Das ist dann praktisch, wenn das Ding
Open Source ist und du auf GitHub einfach ein Issue
aufmachen kannst. Ja, und sonst
schreibe ich halt dem Support und hoffe, dass
die es halt irgendwann mitkriegen. Aber wenn
die halt keiner ihnen sagt und sie es anscheinend nicht selber mitkriegen,
dass dann Leute tatsächlich
daran scheitern, sich Accounts anzulegen, toll.
Ich habe tatsächlich gerade eine coole Idee für
ein GitHub-Projekt
Shadow Repos.
Du legst quasi, wir machen
jetzt die Orga Shadow Repos
und legen dort Repos
für alle Nicht-Open-Source-Anwendungen an.
Wo der Code da nicht drin ist,
aber wo du Issues aufmachen kannst.
Das sehe ich tatsächlich von recht vielen Leuten, die eine Closed-Source-App haben.
Die haben ein Reaper auf GitHub,
wo sie nur Issues tracken, aber der Code
nicht da liegt. Da liegt nur eine Readme drin,
und das machen sie nur Issue-Tracking.
Okay, kann man machen, aber ich finde das schick, das für andere Leute
zu machen.
Das gibt es tatsächlich für GitHub,
sorry, von
dem Isaac Schlüter, der NPM-Typ,
der ursprünglich NPM gebaut hat.
Oder ist auch der? Ja, ich glaube schon.
Der hat ein Issue-Repo
aufgetabt für GitHub,
wo Leute wirklich
über tausende Issues gesammelt haben.
Da habe ich auch schon den gesammelt früher.
Und sammelt halt für GitHub
Issues explizit.
Achso, GitHub-Issues.
Ja, sammelt GitHub-Issues.
Cool.
Ich hatte neulich
eine...
Der hat als Profilbild auf LinkedIn
diesen
Ancient Aliens-Typ.
NPM Inc.
CEO 2014 bis heute.
Das ist der Isaac, genau.
Er hat NPM benutzt, bevor es cool war.
Der war vorher Frontend-Engineer bei Yahoo.
Das stimmt. Und bei Soyent.
Nein, er invented NPM in 2009.
In 2014 er founded a company around it.
Nichts, nichts.
Cool. Ich bin immer noch froh, dass ich NPM direkt selber
nicht mehr benutzen muss.
Ich finde NPM also bedeutend
angenehmer zu nutzen als Jahren.
Aber ich mache echt nichts mit JavaScript, also habe ich da keine Meinung zu,
die irgendwas wert ist. Was ist daran bedeutend, angenehmer zu nutzen?
Die API ist schick, verständlich.
Die API? Also das Interface, ja.
Und es ist nicht irgendwelche Facebook-Server, die es berührt.
Achso, ja, das vergiss ich immer. Das stimmt.
Weil das touchen wir bei uns auf Arbeit überhaupt nicht.
Was ist denn ein NPM für euch? Warum wollt ihr unbedingt Yarn nutzen?
Yarn ist einfach immer noch 20% schneller als NPM.
Ich dachte, es wurde mittlerweile gefixt.
NPM hat
nachgezogen, aber es hat halt
nie aufgeholt. Nicht komplett.
Was ich sinnvoller finde, ist,
dass NPM als Logfiles
JSON verwendet und nicht sein eigenes
Format. Ah, das hast du mal gepasst, das für Jan.
Genau.
Ansonsten ist es ja einfach angenehm
schnell. Das ist alles.
Und wir haben jetzt halt überall Jan Logfiles einmal
drin. Okay, dann ist es halt so.
Okay, verstehe ich. Ich meine, das lässt sich auch wieder umziehen.
Aber ich habe mich irgendwie dran gewöhnt.
Aber es stimmt eigentlich, wenn du drüber nachdenkst.
könnte man auch mal zu NPM zurück, aber
ich habe einmal, ich musste eine Zeit lang
den Code von
von einem größeren Repo,
da war ich der einzige Typ, wo sie gesagt haben, du machst
nur jetzt JavaScript, du guckst da mal mit drauf.
Da ist so ein großes
Bildsystem, wo
innen drin noch 35
so Test
NPM-Module gebaut wurden
mit Dependencies laden und das ist
in der CI so häufig umgefallen
wegen irgendwelchen Unzulänglichkeiten von NPM,
dass ich mich einfach abgewöhnt habe.
als wir das auf Janum gezogen hatten,
das ist irgendwie wesentlich besser geworden.
Das ist einfach ein ganzes Stück weniger buggy. Es kann sein, dass
die das nachgezogen haben, aber ich habe irgendwann mal
im Quelltext von NPM rumgelesen
und habe einfach eine Stelle, die
mich interessiert hatte, habe ich, ohne dass ich
viel weiter drum rumgesucht habe, habe ich aber gesehen,
wie sie eine Variable irgendwie dreimal mit
anderen Typen zuweisen.
Einmal mit was, was sie reinkriegen,
dann einmal mit was, was
der Okay-Zustand ist, ja oder nein,
und dann einmal mit dem, was sie zum Schluss, ich weiß es gar nicht genau,
Was ist denn das für ein Code-Style?
Shadowing finde ich hin und wieder ganz schick.
Aber das ist ja kein Shadowing in JavaScript, das ist ja wirklich das selbe Ding, wie ich weiß.
Shadowing ist so eine Sache,
eigentlich ist es nicht geil, aber wenn du so
Destructuring machst, du kriegst was rein,
was ein Optional zum Beispiel von was ist,
das heißt X
und dann sagst du aber
if let sum X gleich X
und dann innen drin ist es, heißt es genauso.
Genau da finde ich es halt toll.
Ich habe in Zwift echt oft den Fall, dass ich Typen halt,
keine Ahnung, brauche ich halt irgendeinen Platzhalternamen
dafür, dann musst du halt, keine Ahnung,
du kriegst was rein, das ist ein String,
du machst das zu einem Int und dann machst du weiter,
das Ding jetzt halt mit STR so fix hinten,
damit ich den Int-Typen unten so nennen kann,
wie ich ihn wirklich nennen möchte.
Also Typen im variablen Namen kannst du echt nur machen,
wenn du keine Typen hast.
Das ist scheiße, aber du brauchst halt irgendeinen dummen Platzhalter.
NC++, wenn Sachen
unterstrich T heißen,
weil es der Typ von was ist.
Ich haue jetzt Leuten bei Code Reviews auf die Finger,
wenn sie irgendwo im Typnamen Typ schreiben.
Das Typ heißt,
oder das Interface fängt mit I an.
Das ist das Ding, mit dem kann ich überhaupt nicht mich anfangen.
Das machen die
hauptsächlich C-Sharp und Java-Entwickler,
die sowas verbrechen, oder?
Die Java-Leute schreiben ja Interface hin.
Da steckt dir das ganze Wort im Namen.
Ich habe das auch schon gemacht an Stellen, wo du wirklich
über Sprache geredet hast. Wir haben
Code generiert, der anderen Code rappt und dann
also Code, der gut generiert, der gut generiert
ist. Ich erinnere mich.
Und da mussten wir halt echt ein Interface für ein bestimmtes
Ding machen und da konnten wir uns halt keine
Typnamen ausdenken dafür und du konntest
den Namen auch nicht wiederverwenden.
Das Einzige, was du auf Code-Generierungsebene
machen konntest, war noch i vorne dran schreiben.
Nicht schön, aber es ist halt auch ein Code-Generator.
An der Stelle finde ich wieder OKR,
muss ich sagen.
Es ist OKR.
Ich glaube, das wird der Sendungstitel.
Oh Gott, ja, wir können Sprachen.
Das ist, glaube ich, die Sprache
alles diese Folge sehr lang. Warum? Woran liegt's?
Wir haben keine
guten Themen vorbereitet. Ach, wir haben noch
eins. Nämlich haben wir jetzt eine neue Möglichkeit,
wie ihr uns erreichen könnt.
Nämlich sind wir nicht mehr nur noch auf Twitter,
sondern auch natürlich auf Mastodon vertreten.
Da haben wir ja letzte Woche schon mal lange drüber geredet.
Genau. Deswegen wollen wir das heute mal ganz kurz
in Folge 24 anreißen.
Mastodon hat jetzt
einen massiven Push bekommen, weil Twitter immer
scheißer wird. Scheißer. Immer scheißer.
Eines Okayer ist es auch scheißer.
Was macht dann Twitter? Die haben ihre
API, ihre Streaming-API erstmal
abgeschaltet. Das hat
haufenweise Clients zerstört.
Was heißt zerstört? Die wären einfach blöd zu
nutzen. Dann hat Twitter die
Activity-Daten, die
API dicht gemacht, soweit ich weiß. Das heißt,
du kriegst jetzt nicht mehr die Infos von wegen,
wer deine Tweets geliked hat, retweetet hat.
Die ganzen populären Leute
auf Twitter behaupten, ja, ihr habt das aktiviert,
seid ihr doof. Ja, ich kriege halt nicht so viele
Notifications in der Hinsicht, deswegen kann ich
die auch genauso gut anlassen. Das ist mir egal.
So, jemand, der was
der nur mal eben einen Tweet
ablässt, wie sein Mittagessen war
und davor auf gleich 10.000 Likes
kriegt, der, also denkt sie natürlich,
muss ich sowas haben. Eben, verstehe ich auch,
aber mich persönlich stört das nicht.
Ich habe heute was gepostet,
irgendwas,
wo so ein Karo-Muster in grün
und dunkelgrün wieder so ein bisschen aussah, wie
der Activity Graph in GitHub.
Das war auch so eine
Grafik von einem Anzug, von einem Typen
mit einem Anzug mit so einem Muster. Da habe ich
auf Twitter gepostet,
this suit is a better programmer than you.
Da habe ich zwei Likes drauf bekommen,
habe ich mich super drüber gefreut.
Ist doch schön, ist doch wunderbar.
Aber ich meine, das ist das eine, damit können
Third-Party-Clients ja noch leben, theoretisch,
aber die Twitter-RP-Changes gehen ja demnächst noch weiter.
Die machen ja demnächst
die Requests richtig hart zu.
Ich bin mir nicht mehr genau sicher, wie die sagen.
Ich habe gerade eben leider nicht finden können,
die genauen Änderungen. Aber wenn ich mich
recht erinnere, sind das irgendwie ein paar
hundert Requests, die du generell
für alle möglichen Endpoints abschicken kannst,
oder ich glaube 10.000 Tweets
am Tag, aber halt nicht pro
Account, sondern pro Client.
Und das ist halt für Third-Party-Clients
quasi ein Todesstoß und die müssen halt
alle massiv Geld zahlen, um die API dann weiter
zu nutzen und das sind halt für einen populären
Client locker mal so 3.000 bis 10.000 Dollar.
Auf der anderen Seite schreibt, glaube ich,
Twitter immer noch keine schwarzen Zahlen, oder?
Nee, das haben sie noch nie, soweit ich weiß.
Aber das sind halt so Sachen, ja gut, dann können wir
die Third-Party-Client auch gleich sein lassen.
Was gibt es denn an originalen Clients? Der für iOS ist Schrott,
für den Desktop gibt es keine mehr von Twitter,
die haben die eingestellt,
wollen die nicht machen, dann musst du die Webseite nutzen, also kannst du
generell nur noch die Webseite nutzen.
Twitter ist nur so populär, wie es ist,
weil es schon immer diese Client-Vielfalt gab.
Aber nö,
fuck it, lass uns das komplett dicht machen.
Ich muss sagen, ich habe eigentlich bislang überall den
Original-Client verwendet,
bis ich jetzt halt neulich
mich auf Chaos Social
angemeldet habe. Ah ja, genau, jetzt lass uns zu Mastodon gehen.
Und jetzt sind wir auf Mastodon.
Also ihr findet jetzt akronomisierbar und uns beide auf Mastodon.
Ich bin at hoodie at chaos.social und Kilian ist...
Genau, wir haben uns beide den selben Homeserver ausgesucht, beide auf chaos.social.
Ich bin at Kilian at chaos.social.
Das Schöne an Mastodon ist ja, dass das nicht nur ein Betreiber ist, der das hostet,
sondern es ist ein ganz föderiertes System.
Das heißt, es gibt viele, viele Instanzen, die laufen auf unterschiedlichen Domains.
Eine auf Chaos.social.
Man sucht sich eine aus, die irgendwo
seinen eigenen Interessen entspricht, idealerweise.
Muss man aber natürlich auch nicht.
Also die einen gehen zu chaos.social, weil sie sich
im Chaos-Umfeld recht wohlfühlen. Die anderen gehen zu
mastodon.technology,
weil sie sich generell in der
größeren Tech-Szene
wohlfühlen. Wenn du auf Mastodon gehst
und dich irgendwie registrieren willst, wirst du erst mal gefragt,
was sind so deine Interessen? Hier gibt es Pots.
Ne, die heißen nicht Pots. Das ist der Espora, genau.
Die, wo
Leute, was weiß ich, Coder, Künstler,
Man kann sich grob daran orientieren.
Man hat dann eine Local Timeline, wo man quasi
alles sieht, was auf der eigenen Instanz abläuft.
Manche Leute wollen zum Yahoo.Social gehen,
so eine Furry-Instanz. Kannst du da alles
machen, findest du überall deine Community.
So, jetzt werden wir aber mal ein bisschen Meta. Ich habe ja gerade aus Versehen
Pott gesagt.
Das ist ja schön, dass es sowas wie ein föderiertes
alternatives Twitter gibt, aber es ist
2018 auch nicht das Erste.
Nee, natürlich nicht. Vorher gab es
Diaspora. Diaspora ist...
Das war auch lange nicht das Erste. Das war längst
nicht das Erste. Ich weiß, dass ich
eine Zeit lang vor 10 Jahren
Identica verwendet habe. Das war glaube ich nicht
mal föderiert, aber das war
zumindest, doch, das war eine
Open-Source-Alternative.
Es gab
35 Varianten, die
Jabber-basiert waren.
Eine davon war glaube ich
hier aus Dresden von ein paar Leuten
entwickelt worden. Wie hieß denn das?
Ich kriege es gar nicht mehr zusammen. Aber es ist das,
in dessen Rahmen
Jabber XMPP, äh Quatsch,
Node.xmpp gebaut wurde.
Die
Jabber-Implementierung für Node.js
ist hier von Astrolos getreten worden
und wurde für dieses eine, ich weiß gar nicht mehr,
wie es heißt, Buddy.io
oder so ähnlich. Irgendwas gab es da, ja.
Ich weiß aber auch nicht mehr, wie das hieß.
Aber ich meine, jetzt ist,
als ich das erste Mal von Mustern
gehörert habe, gibt es ja auch jetzt schon eine Weile,
habe ich mir gedacht, okay, noch eins.
Na, mal schauen, wie weit das kommt.
Jetzt nimmt es so ein bisschen Fahrt auf.
Ich muss auch sagen, es steckt ein bisschen mehr Liebe drin.
in den anderen. Die meisten sahen so ein bisschen zusammengehackt
aus, wie von so ein paar Hackern
gebaut, die sich das machen.
Hier bei Chaos Social merkst du zumindest,
dass da jemand so ein bisschen Artwork baut.
Es gibt halt gemalte Mastodons.
Ansonsten sieht es aus wie,
wenn ich mir die Webseite angucke,
es ist halt sehr funktional. Es sieht halt aus
wie TweetDeck.
Ich habe auch, glaube ich, keine Variante gesehen, wo ich
nur den Strom sehe, sondern es ist immer
direkt diese Multispaltenansicht.
Aber ansonsten, was kann es eigentlich mehr als
ein normales Twitter, außer dass es
federiert ist? Es hat noch ein paar Features
oben drüber gelegt, die Leute sich schon lange bei Twitter wünschen,
zum Beispiel Content Warnings, die jetzt nicht nur
für den eigentlichen Sinn von Content Warnings
gemacht sind, sondern du kannst auch
einfach deine Punchline von den Witz verstecken, wenn du
möchtest, machen habe ich jetzt schon sehr oft gesehen.
Das ist ein Feature, was echt praktisch ist.
Ach, das ist dieses CW hier. Genau, da gibt es ein Label
oder einen Text, den sieht man dann und der Rest ist versteckt
hinter einem Button, den restlichst du erst,
wenn du dann draufklickst, wenn du manuell zustimmst,
dass du diesen Content sehen möchtest quasi.
Dazu sind sehr viele Leute für natürlich Sachen, die
grenzwertig, anstößig sein könnten.
Also anstößig geht es ja nicht, weil das willst du
generell eigentlich ja nicht mit der Öffentlichkeit posten, es sei denn,
du hast Probleme.
Naja, warte, es gibt
Leute, deren Arbeit ist anstößig.
Okay, anstößig, der findet halt jeder
für sich, das stimmt schon.
Aber ich meine, das exaktive beleidigende Content,
den willst du ja eigentlich nicht ausprobieren.
Aber was ist denn zum Beispiel, wenn
so ein Pornodarsteller irgendwie
einen Twitter-Account hat?
Ist dir überlassen, ob du dein Content-Warning packst oder nicht?
Auf Mastodon würde ich persönlich sagen,
mehr hinter Content Warnings packen,
als mal notwendig.
Einzig und allein weiß halt
diese Local Timeline und auch diese Federated Timeline
gibt, wo Leute echt oft sehen,
was so generell noch mit
im Fediverse, sagt man ja, so schön
abgeht.
Fediverse, so wie Federated First?
Das ist Federated Universe, ja.
Das Schöne an Mastodon ist ja noch ein anderes Feature.
Es implementiert ja nicht nur die Federation für das eigene Protokoll,
sondern Mastodon nutzt ja dieses Activity Pub oder OS-Datus.
Genau, also eigentlich ist es ja eine Implementierung
von GnuSocial.
Die auch dieses Protokoll implementieren, genau.
Das heißt, du kannst auch anderen Plattformen
auf Mastodon folgen. Das heißt, du kannst
Richard Stormen auf GnuSocial mit deinem Mastodon-Account
folgen. Habe ich jetzt lange gemacht. Der Typ ist eine ziemliche
Linkschleuder, deswegen lasse ich das wieder.
Der schreibt auch nicht persönlich,
der postet nur Links. Mastodon ist doch wahrscheinlich
eine Rails-Anwendung, oder?
Ich behaupte, ja, das ist eine Rails-Anwendung.
So, auf was für einem Format
abonnieren Sie es gegenseitig?
Also wenn ich jetzt irgendwie 35.000
Instanzen habe,
Ich überlege bloß, wie das skaliert. Also wenn ich 35.000
Instanzen habe und auf jeder folgt
einer nur einer anderen, das ist ja
ein extrem fein vermaschendes Netz, gibt es da irgendwie
so ein System wie bei E-Mail, wo ich sage,
ich kenne den über fünf Ecken, ich leite
das mal für dich weiter, dann sind die Wege.
Das würde mich aber tatsächlich jetzt auch passieren.
Da möchte ich mir fast gerne mal einen Tech Talk zu anhören,
wie eigentlich die Federation da funktioniert.
Das wäre doch mal was, was man herausfinden könnte.
Gut, hier YouTube-Research.
Aber es gibt halt sehr viele in der Richtung. Es gibt ja auch mittlerweile
Peertyp zum Beispiel, was so ein YouTube-Klon
auf BitTuber-Torrent-Basis ist.
Und da kannst du auch
Peertube-Accounts abonnieren mit deinem
Mastodon-Account, weil das halt alles
auf dieselbe Federated-Protokoll spricht.
Das ist klasse. Ich finde das großartig.
Das sind all diese Sachen, über die ich
in dieser Folge Peak Web 3.0
mal reden wollte, wo man dann gesagt hat,
es gibt doch auch dieses D-Tube.
Das ist hier wieder nochmal eine andere
Richtung mit diesen DApps,
diesen Distributed-Apps.
Da verstehe ich aber ehrlich gesagt auch noch nicht komplett,
was die machen.
Das sieht aber mittlerweile schon sehr hart an YouTube-Authier.
Finde ich gut.
Du hast Vorschaubilder, wo Leute irgendwie...
Ja, aber die ganze UI mit der Sidebar
und dem Button da oben und...
Das ist schon doll angelehnt.
Finde ich sinnvoll.
Etablierte UIs klauen ist toll.
Ach so. Ich finde das super.
Da findet man sich gleich zurecht.
Ja, man findet 40-jährige was zu Hause.
Als GitLab am Anfang genauso aussah wie GitHub,
haben alle gesagt, was ist das für eine Abkupferung?
Jetzt machen sie ihr eigenes Ding und jedes Mal,
wenn ich mal auf einer GitLab-Seite bin,
denke ich mir, hätten sie das nicht genauso gemacht.
ein Mastodon-Frontend, das heißt
Halcyon.
Twitter.rix.
Rix ist einer der Admins von Chaos.social
und der hostet diesen Mastodon-Client
und da logst du dich ein mit dem Mastodon-Account
und das sieht eins zu eins aus wie die Twitter-Frontpage.
Und da fühlt man sich auch wieder
ein bisschen mehr zu Hause gleich.
Ja, stimmt. Da gebe ich jetzt hier meinen Account ein.
Was ich bei Mastodon...
Also nochmal auf die Meta-Ebene zurück.
Diese ganzen
Iterationen von...
einen Link geschickt. Ne, ich hab den Tweet, dein
Toot gefaved. Achso.
Toot gefaved.
Ich toote das mal.
Tweeten lang anfangs genauso dumm.
Ich hab einen Kumpel,
dessen Namen ich jetzt nicht nenne, der irgendwie immer
Toot, Tun, Infinitiv
verwendet. Okay.
Und ich mir denke, nee, das klingt ein bisschen
komisch. Aber zumindest noch mal
auf die Meta-Ebene zurück, die ganzen Sachen, die
auf Jabber basiert haben, hatten ja das Schöne
an Jabber, dass eigentlich die JID,
die JID, die Jabber
quasi eine E-Mail-Adresse
slash Instanz.
Das heißt, ich konnte mit fünf Clients
sein, denen habe ich einen Namen gegeben und da war
meine
Jabber-ID war dann
hoodie at
jabbercc.de
slash
Psy oder slash zu Hause oder
slash auf Arbeit.
Instanzen finde ich wieder super eklig,
wie das bei Jabber gehandhabt wird.
Aber da kannst du zumindest sagen,
der ist mit drei Clients gerade online,
es skaliert nicht mehr mit der heutigen,
wir haben fünf Geräte und sie sind alle gleichzeitig
online mit, aber du konntest zumindest sagen, ich lasse das zu Hause
an, dann konnte ich mir eine Nachricht nach Hause schicken
oder ich sehe wohl...
Oder ich schicke an alle gleichzeitig,
beziehungsweise Psy hatte dieses schicke Feature, dass du sagen kannst,
ich schicke dem
anderen Client von mir, der gerade läuft,
was ist hier auf Arbeit, schicke ich mal den Befehl,
dass er mir alle Nachrichten, die ich empfangen habe,
seitdem ich da nicht mehr aktiv bin,
noch hierher umleitet oder sowas. Das ist eigentlich ganz
cool. Aber jetzt hier
die Mastodon-IDs, die
haben ein Doppel-Ad. Das ist immer
dein Handel mit einem
Ad anfangt, Ad Kilian
und dann aber
Ad Chaos Social.
Warum ist das nicht Kilian, Ad Chaos Social?
Meine Vermutung
ist an der Stelle, bei Mastodon weiß ich es nicht,
aber für andere Plattformen,
dass du auch hier ähnlich dem Twitter-Style
Ad-Handles nutzen kannst,
um Leute zu mentionen und das direkt vom Client
sauber verstanden wird. Ich vermute, da kommt
und der Rest der Syntax mit
add car social, logisch, dass du das als Trennzeichen nutzt.
Schlimmer finde ich es bei Matrix, die
add username, Doppelpunkt server name
sagen. Das wirkt einfach
sehr kaputt, aber okay, wenn ihr das so machen
wollt, meinetwegen.
Da frage ich mich dann auch eher, warum ich einfach
die klassische E-Mail-Adressen
schreibe. Also Matrix hat die Begründung dafür,
dass sie das ja auch andere Sachen
noch da nutzen, ob Raum-Identifier sind
Octothorpe, also Fundzeichen,
also Hashtag, also keine Ahnung, wie nennt man das noch?
Raute, Gatter,
Zaun. Was wollte ich gerade sagen?
Hashtag. Pound.
Ich weigere mich, das Ding als Hashtag zu bezeichnen.
Habe ich doch gerade als Beispiel mitgenommen.
Raute, Raumname,
Doppelpunkt, Servername. Und weil es halt für
verschiedene Sachen gibt es auch noch Ausrufezeichen,
ID für irgendwas, die nutzen halt verschiedene
Zeichen als Identifier für die Typen,
dann der Name von dem, was auch immer das ist,
Doppelpunkt der Servername. Und da haben sie halt dafür eine
relativ einheitliche Syntax für sich selber definiert.
Also das lässt sich halt an der Stelle machen.
Warte, Notifications aus hier.
Pst, Entschuldigung.
Also lässt sich an der Stelle halt machen, aber das ist
nicht etabliert, aber
meinetwegen, wenn ihr das machen wollt,
ich finde es ein bisschen weird, auch wie du schon gesagt hast,
für Mastodon, dass wir auch hier die ID zu machen,
aber meinetwegen ist halt so.
Jetzt muss ich aufpassen, dass ich, ich habe wirklich auch
auf Chaos Social
auf Mastodon genau das gleiche Hintergrundbild
und das gleiche
Account-Bild genommen wie
auf Twitter.
Jetzt habe ich echt Probleme, dass ich es selber
mit euch kann. Aber cool, ja,
das ist mal was. Local und Federated.
Genau.
Bei einem Feature, wo ich mir dachte, das ist nice
bei Mastodon, was sich herausgestellt hat,
war bloß bei dem einen Client, den ich vorwendet habe,
ist, du konntest Sachen nicht
nur starren, sondern auch bookmarken.
Das wäre, was ich gerne als
Server-Feature gehabt hätte.
Man benutzt ständig irgendwie Likes für was,
damit du sagst, ich möchte die Spiele noch mal reingucken,
das möchte ich mir immer merken, aber das mischt sich
dann mit. Ich mag das und ich möchte mir das merken.
Ist ja nicht unbedingt das Gleiche.
Twitter hat es ja noch kaputter gemacht, indem sie angefangen haben,
gelikete Tweets auch deinen Followern
zu zeigen als von dir gelikete
und somit promotete Tweets.
Ich kann auf Mastodon nichts mehr staren,
weil ich denke, also ich meine,
ich fühle mich nicht schlecht bei den Sachen, die ich starre, aber ich habe gleich das Gefühl,
damit schämen mich doch meine Follower zu. Nein,
Staren hat damit nichts zu tun. Scheiß Twitter,
ihr macht alles kaputt. Aber das Staren,
das andere Leute sehen, ist das, was bei
GitHub gerade nur wieder interessant ist.
Ja, stimmt, aber wir brauchen eine einheitliche
Sprache für das Internet.
Ja, also ich möchte, genau, ich möchte
drei Sachen mindestens unterscheiden können.
Ich möchte was liken können, damit ich demjenigen,
der das gemacht hat, sagen kann, finde ich cool.
Ich möchte was bookmarken können,
damit ich für mich sagen kann,
schau ich später nochmal rein.
Finde ich cool.
Finde ich nützlich, muss ich nochmal hingucken.
Und dann möchte ich was empfehlen können.
Mit dem Hinweis, finde ich cool.
Finde ich cool, genau.
Das eine ist eine Message an den
Creator,
das andere ist eine Message an mich selbst,
so für später.
Und das andere ist
eine Promotion an die Öffentlichkeit.
Das sollte man...
Also Leute, die hier Mastodon entwickelt, ich möchte bitte
Star und Bookmarken und
boosten können.
Fände ich praktisch, in der Tat.
Ne, schreibt uns mal auf
at akonomisierbar at chaos.social
Wir sind da erreichbar.
Oder at toddy at chaos.social
oder at kiran at chaos.social
Genau, unsere Handles unterscheiden sich, weil wir nämlich
die Namen
endlich benutzen konnten, die wir benutzen wollen.
ich glaube damit können wir uns jetzt auch mal
zusammenpassen. Ja, vielmehr zu Mastodon nicht
zu sagen, das ist, ja
genau, schreibt uns eure Meinung doch mal
Genau, folgt uns auf
Mastodon, ich glaube auf Chaos Social
kann man sich leider nicht mehr anmelden. Aktuell nicht
zu viel User-Influx dank der
Twitter-Scheiße
Genau, würde ich sagen
so viel erstmal zu den Topics für heute, oder? Genau
Ja, ich hätte jetzt schon fast gesagt
ich glaube das reicht jetzt langsam, aber wir können auch gerne
noch ein, zwei Stars nachreichen
für die Leute, die...
Stars, Stars, Stars, Stars.
Wir bräuchten so einen Jingle mit
irgendwelchen Welcome to the Stars.
I'll show you the stars.
Egal. Also, kommen wir zu den Stars.
Was hast du denn so gestartet?
Ich habe, so wie viele andere wahrscheinlich
gefunden, diese tolle
Electron-App, die Windows 95
hat. Ganz großartig. Liefern dir eigentlich
wirklich das gesamte Windows 95
beinahe mit? Ich wollte noch reinschauen,
was da genau eigentlich drinsteckt, aber es ist
halt, so wie es sich anfühlt, genauso
kacke wie ein echtes Windows 95.
Das fühlt sich nicht an wie ein Fake Windows 95
Kriegen die Probleme mit Microsoft, dass sie das irgendwie ausliefern?
Ich meine, Windows 95 ist auch noch keine 70 Jahre alt
und hat kein Copyright mehr drauf
Ich muss ehrlich gesagt mal reinschauen
Aber es ist super fancy und ich finde es super witzig
Und das ist halt, warum nicht
eine gute Möglichkeit für die Zukunft
um sowas wie alte Spiele am Leben zu halten
Packst du eine Electron App, die das ganze System
emotiert
Warum nicht?
Wird wahrscheinlich darauf hinauslaufen, dass du demnächst
irgendwie
die aktuellsten Spiele, was weiß ich,
Fortnite,
dann irgendwann als
voll virtualisierte
WebAssembly-Anwendung direkt im Browser
spielst. In zehn Jahren.
Warum nicht? Genau.
Ne, also Windows 95 als Elektron-App
funktioniert erstaunlich gut, ist
mehr ein Witzge.
Mein Star ist ein ganz kleines Ding,
es ist natürlich immer wieder was im Rust.
Es ist das Create
Include Deer, und zwar
gibt es in Rust
herrlich produktive Makros,
die einfach dadurch
möglich werden, dass du einen Compiler hast.
Und zwar sowas wie
includeFile oder includeString oder
includeBytes.
includeBytes sagt
hier diese Datei,
inklude mir das mal hier, also du sagst
letVariableName
equals includeBytes und dann gibst du eine Datei
an und die wird zur CompileTime
gelesen und als Byte
an dieser Stelle als wertigste Variable reingeschmissen.
Das gleiche geht für includeString.
IncludeFiles inkludiere den Code von dieser anderen Rust-Datei hier rein,
das ist was anderes, aber includeString sagt,
inkludiere mir diese Datei, lies die zur Compile-Zeit ein,
inklude mir das als String an dieser Stelle,
was super praktisch ist, zum Beispiel Default-Config für ein Tool,
was ich gebaut habe.
Die Config ist in YAML und die Default-Config baust du einfach,
indem du die YAML-Datei selber in deinem Compile-Ordner mit dazu baust
und sagst include string, dann hast du die Datei geladen
und dann wird die
als String in deiner Binary mit rumgeschleppt.
Ist super praktisch. Wäre natürlich noch schöner,
wenn du so einen const expression
parse Aufruf hättest, wo du sagen kannst,
lad mir diese Datei
und parse die noch zur Compile Time, weil die wird sich ja
ähnlich nochmal ändern. Das wäre auch sehr schön.
Ja, weil sonst, wenn du eine falsche Datei parsst,
also eine invalide Datei
includest, dann ist sie halt
deine Binary, das kannst du wegschmeißen, weil
die halt immer falsch ist.
Aber für andere Sachen gibt es jetzt auch
include dir und da
kriegst du quasi so ein Pseudo-Directory-Object
zurück, du gibst einfach
ein Verzeichnis an und der
lädt einfach alle Dateien rein
und du kannst auf dem Ding, was du dann da als auf der linken Seite
stehen hast, kannst du mit auf Pfade zugreifen
und ja, die ganzen Sachen.
Das kann, je nachdem wie groß es ist, extrem lange dauern.
Aber ich
habe zum Beispiel jetzt für mein kleines
ASCII-Tool, wo ich eine REST-Anwendung
zugebaut habe, da habe ich einfach zum Spaß die gesamte
Frontend-Geschichte da statisch
in das Binary reinkompiliert, haben wir ja am Anfang schon mehr erlebt.
Und das hast du dann gemacht? Und das geht damit, da sagst du einfach
hier, include dir und dann
.. slash Web App
und dadurch, dass das Weltteil so schön klein ist,
ist die Binary immer noch super klein
gewesen zum Schluss.
Und ich meine, das sind auch bloß drei Dateien, das hätte ich auch
irgendwie so machen können, aber
super schick. Das ist ja wahrscheinlich auch bloß ein
Makro-Wapper, um include-bytes, oder?
Auf jeden Fall, auf jeden Fall.
Warum nicht? Schicke Idee.
Super nice, genau.
Du nochmal.
Ich habe noch ein Tool, das heißt FZF.
Das ist der Fuzzy Finder oder so, heißt das.
Das ist ein Command Line Fuzzy Finder.
Und ich nutze es hauptsächlich für das Tastaturkürsel,
was das mitbringt, nämlich STRG R.
Er überschreibt schön dieses andere Ding,
was man halt nutzt, um in seiner History rekursiv zu suchen
und macht es einfach so tausendmal besser.
Es ist so angenehm, wenn du das Ding aufmachst
und da einfach mal drauf lostippst,
Vor allem, weil du halt eine ganze History siehst.
Du kannst da durchgehen.
Du siehst halt nicht nur
den letzten Command. In meinem Filz davon kann man sich auch noch machen.
Mit anderen Tools. Aber ich finde das
super angenehm in der Nutzung.
FZF.
Ich wäre ungern der Tipps, der sagt, oh, ich kenne da was
in Rust, weil das hier ist in Go geschrieben.
Oh, schlimm. Wie kann ich nur?
Nee, aber wenn es gut funktioniert, ich nutze viel Go.
Genau.
Vollkommen in Ordnung.
Ich war dabei, als irgendjemand im Userforum
in Rust geschrieben hat,
Rusty so vorgeschrieben hat. Ich hab da mal
was ähnliches gebaut wie FZF.
So und so. Hier, das macht genau
das gleiche. Hier ist es als Wim-Plugin.
Das ist nämlich das Schöne. Du kannst es als Wim-Plugin
benutzen und dann hast du so
Fuzzy Search auf deinem Projektordner,
wie du es
bei VS Code oder anderen Editoren kennst.
Halt auch in Wim.
Und hier bei dem
Skim heißt das, genau.
Bei dem Skim hat er gefragt, wie soll es heißen?
Dann hab ich geschrieben Skim.
Du hast den Namen dafür gegeben.
Und jetzt heißt es skim, weil ich gesagt habe...
Das sieht aber tatsächlich dem sehr, sehr ähnlich.
Genau. Das ist fast das Gleiche. Das ist das, was ich
verwende. Die Abkürzung ist SK.
Das ist so ein Zeichen kürzer.
Ich nutze Steuerung R.
Achso, du hast das echt als... Wie legt man das
auf Steuerung R?
Der Installer hat...
Als ich es runtergezogen habe, meinte, soll ich die Keyboard nicht einrichten?
Klar, mach mal!
Okay, cool. Also ich sage dann
SK, Pipe,
Wim oder sowas und dann tippe ich das ein.
und dann macht er das Wimble.
Ach so, so machst du das, okay.
Warum nicht? Aber solche Tools sind toll.
Genau, das ist super schön.
Ein weiteres Tolles Wask-Zili-Tool.
In der schönen Tradition, du hast einen Star und ich will
dann einfach eine Alternative dazu.
Die Wask-Zili-Alternative.
Es ist ja generell gerade cool, dass man so viele
Zili-Tools in Waskner schreibt, dass es
FD gibt, Ripgrab gibt, dass es
Bad gibt. Das ist ja,
da gibt es echt tolle viele Tools.
Eine andere Sache, die ich noch habe, das ist Swift Syntax.
Das ist, dass
die Swift-Syntax-Bibliothek ausgezogen,
nicht ausgezogen, rausgezogen
in das eigene Swift-PM-Package.
Super cool, kann man jetzt einbinden,
damit Dinge zu machen. Habe ich persönlich
noch nicht genutzt, will ich aber mal noch
in mein altes Projekt mal reinziehen.
Das ist quasi einfach der Swift-Parser aus dem
Copiler raus. Das ist nicht der eigentliche Swift-Parser,
sondern ein in Swift geschriebener Swift-Syntax
Parsen und generieren kann.
Du kannst den
hast ja auch wieder raus erzeugen.
Das ist nice, das ist nice.
Also wenn diese ganze Parserschreiberei
einmal jemand für dich gemacht hat und dir was anbietet,
was damit arbeiten kann, das ist alles wesentlich.
Ja, und ich hoffe, dass ich hiermit jetzt auch
viel DevTooling noch darauf aufbaut.
Da fehlt ja echt noch einiges, was man dann
in den Packet Transmit einziehen kann.
Da freue ich mich drauf, dass da Dinge entstehen.
Cool, auf jeden Fall, nice.
Ja, das ist, als ich
diesen CodeGen, diesen
Type
Guard Generator
da immer noch nicht veröffentlicht habe.
Ich habe auch gedacht, eigentlich schön,
ich habe jetzt irgendwie ein paar Stunden investiert, um mich mit dem Ding
auseinanderzusetzen, aber jetzt ist eigentlich relativ schön,
irgendwie was zu schreiben, wurde
am Anfang gesagt, pass mir das
an den Compiler, der macht die ganzen
Syntaxunarten für mich weg
und gibt mir einfach ein Objekt, auf dem ich
rumiterieren kann.
Dann kannst du eigentlich noch andere schöne Sachen rausziehen.
Das ist eigentlich ganz nice.
Der Typ, der But geschrieben hat,
also dieses farbige Cut.
Ich habe B-U-T-T gerade im Kopf.
Bett. Ja, der Bett geschrieben hat.
Der hat sich ja darauf verlassen können, dass er einfach
die ganzen Syntax-Highlighting-Dateien
von Sublime verwendet hat.
Die sind extrem...
Sie sind nicht schon von TextMate übernommen oder so?
Weiß ich nicht, aber sie sind zumindest sehr verbos und du könntest
einfach relativ einfache Farben dran geben, aber du weißt bei jedem
Wort bei den Dingern
dadurch relativ genau, das ist jetzt so eine Variable oder so eine Variable.
du hast extrem viel Information pro Begriff,
pro Token in den Dingern.
Und der hat damit nicht nur
klassische
Referenzimplementierung von
seinem Syntax, was diese
Syntax-Highlighting-Library ist, war halt,
dass er dieses SynCut, beziehungsweise jemand anders,
dieses But gebaut hat, was einfach ein Cut
mit Syntax-Highlighting ist, aber der konnte
halt auch andere schöne Sachen machen, wie zum Beispiel
ein wesentlich schlaueres
Log-Tool, also was dir nicht nur
Lines of Code ausgibt und alle Kommentare
und schließenden Klammerzeilen wegmacht,
sondern das könntet ihr auch sagen, so und so
viele Klassen, so und so viele Funktionen,
weil die Syntax-Halletting-Dateien
sind ja quasi minimale
Parser auf dem Ding.
Das ist alles Regular Expression
basiert, aber es ist immer noch in der Lage zu
erkennen, das ist eine Funktion, das ist eine Variable,
das ist ein Keyword, das ist sowas.
Und das reicht immerhin aus, es reicht nicht,
um in Aster raus zu generieren, sollte man wahrscheinlich
nicht, aber es reicht aus, um
so statistische Aussagen über den Code zu machen.
Das ist clever.
Ein anderes Tool, mit dem ich jetzt die letzten Tage mal rumgespielt habe,
ist ja noch so eine Hölle, wenn man so
Webentwickler ist, ist Bundling.
Webpack ist dir ein Begriff?
Rollup ist dir ein Begriff?
Nee.
Nee, also macht quasi genau das Gleiche.
Die Nacht ist lang und voller Schrecken.
Wenn du JavaScript schreibst,
gibt es ja 35 Modulsysteme,
die sich langsam erst so rauskristallisieren
mit ES6-Modulen.
Und jetzt kommt erst raus,
jetzt entwickelt sich auch langsam,
dass die Browsers unterstützen,
aber was du trotzdem möchtest,
dass deine Anwendungen zu einem Paket zusammenschlüsselst,
dass du nur eine Datei ausliefern musst.
Die kann dann gerne 600k groß sein oder sowas,
aber du musst sie halt nur einmal runterladen.
Beziehungsweise du kannst es,
Webpack macht sowas für dich.
Webpack macht auch Optimierung.
Also wenn ich meine Svelte-Anwendung,
die zum Schluss 30k groß war,
nicht mit Webpack mit Optimierung baue,
ist sie dann trotzdem 180k groß,
weil es einfach die ganzen Funktionsnamen,
Funktionsnahm und sowas immer noch
ausgeschrieben sind und so weiter und so fort, beziehungsweise
Leerzeichen und Eindrückungen.
Das macht alles Webpack.
Um es mal zusammenzufassen,
ein cooles Tool, was ich jetzt gesehen habe, das Problem mit
Webpack ist, du musst es eine Weile
tweaken und konfigurieren,
damit es schnell wird, weil es per
Default gewisse Optimierungen macht, die es
Leben für dich einfacher machen.
Und im
Entwicklungszyklus ist es häufig so, dass du,
wenn du speicherst und dann
auf dem
Browser wechselst, um anzugucken, was da passiert.
Webpack startet so einen schönen Server für dich
oder beziehungsweise lauft Tests durch
und aktualisiert es automatisch, wenn du
was gespeichert hast.
Aber es ist langsam. Das heißt,
es wird dir manchmal passieren, dass du speicherst,
rübergehst, testest, neu lädst,
testest und dann, warum
ist das jetzt nicht passiert? Weil zu dem Zeitpunkt,
der Bild noch nicht fertig war.
Okay, ja, passiert.
Dafür gibt es jetzt, genau das ist der Werbeslogan
von Pax oder Pax.
Pax.js.org
schnellste Packager der Welt,
der super
schnell ist, weil er
einfach die JavaScript-Datei nicht wirklich
passt, sondern nur einigermaßen erkennt,
das ist ein Modul, der versteht quasi nur
Import
und Require-Syntax
und ist einfach mal an der Stelle, wo sowas wie
Rollup, ich habe es heute auf Arbeit mal verglichen, bei einem
Projekt, wo irgendwie 1,6
oder 1,5 Sekunden gebraucht hat,
braucht er hier 10 Millisekunden.
Das ist ein starker
Unterschied.
Und das hat auch einen Watch-Modus.
Es ist einfach bloß ein Bundler
für den Entwicklungsprozess.
Also wenn du es ausliefern möchtest, dann nimmst du bitte
irgendwie ein Webpack oder was anderes. Aber während du
JavaScript schreibst,
dann kannst du das nehmen und es einfach
rasend schnell. Was es auch nicht kann,
was viele,
was diese Bundler normalerweise mitbringen,
ist so eine Loader-API. Das heißt,
wenn ich jetzt nicht
JavaScript pur schreibe, sondern sowas wie
TypeScript oder CoffeeScript,
oder Rust, was nach WebAssembly
kompiliert, dann kann ich das
bei Webpack
einfach importen, als wäre es JavaScript.
Und was das Webpack dann für mich
macht, ist, dass es erkennt. Oder
die Dateiendung muss ich noch durch
irgendeinen Compiler durchjagen.
Und das macht er für mich im Hintergrund. Pax macht
das überhaupt nicht. Was aber auch nicht so schlimm ist,
weil ich kann neben dem Ding
einfach den Compiler im Watch-Mode
laufen lassen. Der baut
dann für mich von Source nach Lib,
irgendwie TS nach JavaScript
und das watcht dann der
Bundler für mich. Okay, und das ist dann ähnlich
schnell dann immer noch? Das ist immer noch vergleichbar schnell, weil
der Compiler dann nur die einzelne Datei, die ich
wirklich gerade gespeichert habe,
neu generiert und nicht das gesamte
Ding nochmal von vorne anfasst. Okay, was die Pipeline bedeutet, schneller
als gesamt. Genau. Das ist auch schön.
So, packs. Und ich benutze diese
schöne, ich müsste gerade mal in unseren Show Notes gucken,
ob ich das irgendwann vielleicht sogar schon mal erwähnt habe.
Vollste Folge, ja. Tatsächlich
erinnere mich. Du meinst, dass die auf
JS.org irgendwie Dinge... Oh, fuck. Gut, dann
ich das nicht erzählt.
Jetzt werben die Leute von Akronomie
über ihre Stars schon wieder auf.
Nee, du hast nicht über Packs geredet,
aber du hast über JS.org geredet.
Achso. Stimmt, ich hatte irgendwas anderes, was
auf JS.org gehostet war, oder?
Ja, ich weiß aber nicht, was.
Oder hast du mir das einfach mal erzählt?
Ah ja, fritzbox.js.org.
Habe ich das mal erzählt?
What?
Das kann ich nochmal erwähnen.
Ich habe mir jetzt,
Ich war bei meinen Eltern zu Hause.
Meine Eltern haben diverse von diesen Fritzbox
Powerline-Dosen.
Ich wurde
gebeten von meiner Mutter, du sag mal, wir haben
hier in der Küche eine Alexa, können wir nicht mal irgendwie machen,
dass ich damit das Licht an- und ausmachen kann?
Und ich so, ja klar, du hast doch so eine Powerline-Dose.
Eine Powerline-Dose kannst du über eine API
sagen Strom oder aus.
Innerhalb von der Fritzbox kannst du die einzelnen
Dinge anschalten. Es gibt irgendwie von Fritz eine App,
wo du einfach auf,
du gehst einfach im Browser auf fritz.box
slash myfritz und dann siehst du die Geräte aufgelistet
kannst einfach an- und ausmachen, sowas.
Und bei Alexa gibt es bestimmt irgendeinen Skill
bei Amazon Echo. Und da habe ich reingeguckt,
das war eine übelste Hackerei.
Weil du musstest quasi auf deiner
Fritz, also die Fritzbox, das Schöne an Fritz,
an den AVM-Sachen ist, dass das alles
innerhalb, die gesamte Logik ist innerhalb von der
Fritzbox, es gibt keinen Cloud oder
irgendwas. Du kannst dir
einen MyFritz-Account bei denen machen,
wenn du irgendwie von extern,
wenn du sowas wie DIN-DNS machen möchtest,
möchtest irgendwie von extern drauf zugreifen können,
ohne dass du irgendwie eine Domain freigibst, dann gehst du irgendwie
Fritz logge ich da ein und dann hast du kommuniziert dorthin deine Fritzbox, wer sie ist.
Aber es ist jetzt nicht so eine Art DNS wirklich, sondern es ist ein bisschen einfacher.
Und jetzt um diesem Echo-Skill zu erlauben, dass du sagen kannst, mach mal ein Gerät, was so eine Powerline-Dose ist, an oder aus,
musste ich quasi einen extra Account auf der Fritzbox einrichten, beziehungsweise einen extra Account auf MyFritz einrichten,
dem ich nur Smart Home Capabilities gebe, damit ich die Credentials davon dann diesem Skill weiterreichen kann.
damit das Echo quasi an die
Amazon Cloud funkt,
füllen wir diese Skill aus, damit das mit
MyFritz redet, damit das zurück zu meiner
Fritzbox redet. Das geht also einmal um die gesamte Welt.
Damit ich in der Küche
sagen kann,
mach das Licht in der Küche aus.
Ich muss überlegen, was für eine Architektur
dahinter steckt. Da gab es eine schöne
Folge von
Big Bang Theory, wo sie irgendwie
Home Automation gemacht haben und gesagt haben,
dass sie sich gefreut haben, dass sie alle Lampen jetzt von
irgendwelchen Leuten in Russland steuern lassen konnten.
Und das habe ich gebastelt.
Das hat irgendwie viel zu lange gedauert, das irgendwie
gerade einzurichten. Das hat auch eine Stunde später schon wieder
nicht mehr zuverlässig funktioniert.
Da hat das Alexa dann gesagt, ich kann
leider Licht in der Küche nicht erreichen.
Ich meinte, das reicht.
Ich habe irgendwann vor Ewigkeiten schon mal rumgespielt,
irgendwie die
API selber anzusprechen.
Es gibt Fritzbox.js.
Damit kannst du so gewisse Sachen abfragen,
wie, wer hat gerade angerufen, die Home Automation
Zeugs machen soll noch nicht, aber die API
ist da.
Und ich hatte dann nochmal gebastelt, ob ich das irgendwie
mit
irgendwas bauen könnte. Ich habe genau gesehen,
wir hatten für das ASCII
so eine Stromsteckdose nämlich mal gekauft
und dann saß ich im ASCII so einen Abend da und habe
gebastelt, ob ich irgendwie für ein Raspberry was bauen könnte,
was diese Dose abfragt, um zu wissen,
wie viel Strom das Ding gerade verbraucht,
um dir irgendwie über so einen
Online-Dienst sagen zu können, ob gerade
die Kaffeemaschine in Betrieb ist oder nicht.
Damit du unterscheiden kannst, ob sie wirklich aktiv ist
oder im Standby-Betrieb ist.
Das ist zum Schluss nicht gegangen, weil diese
Kaffeemaschine wesentlich mehr Leistung gezogen hat,
als die Powerline-Dose
in ihrer Spezifikation erlaubt hat.
Ich muss aber darauf hinweisen, dass
3000 Wads sind, was die Kaffeemaschine
da zieht. Das ist halt eine große,
vollautomatische Kaffeemaschine mit
einem Windows-Touch-Display.
Das stimmt, das ist ein Windows, was da drauf läuft.
Das war exakt ein Jahr her, da habe ich schon mal
eine Runde gebastelt, um
das hinzukriegen, dass ich mir
so eine Session-ID von der Fritzbox holen kann,
um die dann weiter zu verwenden,
um das REST-Interface von diesen
Boxen anzusprechen.
Und viel weiter war ich nicht gekommen, weil
allein das Passwort
in ein UTF-16
MD5-Hash umzurechnen
für mich schon so eine
abendfüllende Veranstaltung war, die ich dann keine Lust mehr hatte.
Aber das habe ich jetzt immer wieder
ausgegraben. Ich nehme fritzbox.js
als Referenz-Ambilimentierung
für Sachen und bastel das dann in
fritzbox.rs um.
Nice. Das ist doch cool.
Ich hatte gesehen, du hast mal dieses REST-Projekt
damals geschrieben, aber ich wusste gar nicht, dass die so eine
ausgearbeitete API haben, wo man wirklich Dinge
lokal machen kann. Es entwickelt sich so ein bisschen weiter, also das Feature,
was ich jetzt gerne genutzt hätte, um die
Dose,
ach ja genau,
also so eine Stromsteckdose per API
an- und ausmachen, ging schon
vor einem Jahr, aber was erst
seit ein paar Wochen laut API
geht, ist, dass du dir von der Fritzbox die Liste der
existierenden Geräte,
der angemeldeten Geräte aufgeben
lassen kannst. Das heißt, ich hätte vorher die IP
oder von der Stromdose wissen müssen.
Die kannst du dir bei der Fritzbox statisch vergeben,
dann kriegt die immer dieselbe Sache.
Genau, ich meine, wenn du schlau genug bist, dann geht das auch.
Wenn ihr, liebe Zuhörer, irgendwie
Home-Automation-Zeugs macht und
Fritzbox-Powerline-Dosen
für sowas verwendet, dann schreibt mir doch mal bitte
eure Erfahrung. Gerne auf
at hoodie at kaiossocial.
Genau.
Ich glaube, damit sind meine Stars jetzt auch erschöpft.
Damit sind wir für heute dann auch
wieder mal durch, würde ich behaupten.
Ja, ich bin sehr durch. Ich brauche jetzt erstmal eine Mate und Keks.
Also vielen lieben Dank, liebe Zuhörer.
Bitte schreibt uns Feedback auf
atakronomisierbar auf Twitter
oder atakronomisierbar
at carsocial auf
mastodon.
Genau.
Uns findet ihr auf beiden Plattformen.
Wir sind einfach die beiden,
denen der Akronomisierbar
Account folgt.
Genau.
Wir hören uns hoffentlich beim nächsten Mal wieder.
Das war akronomisierbar Folge 24.
To 4.
Und der nächste Podcast
in eurem Podcatcher bildet in
3, 2, 1.